it yeah
it's just uh
okay uh in the comment section if you
guys if you would you drop off a drop in
the comment section uh where was i
when i got cut off you were talking
about mgtow guys and uh yeah and [ __ ]
like that
okay hold on one second let me try to
get my stream going this shit's [ __ ]
up how many we got in there right now
all right they're probably all trying to
pour in
i think we had about 20 or 30 of them in
there
yeah we just got to move over the other
stream just move over
we'll give them time to show up
ammonium people
room for everybody yeah
well there's only six right now
let me cut my
um
cut my data down
they'll be here in a minute i told
pookie yesterday that she was lucky she
was a cat and she didn't have to deal
with this [ __ ] all the time cats don't
have to deal with it because i have
three computers and it's like none of
them work worth of [ __ ]
but they all have different things wrong
with them i don't think that's your
computer doing that
well no that's this computer is actually
my newest one yeah i don't think that's
the computer but yeah it's that's yeah
i'm just saying that it's just computer
[ __ ] in general whether it's my computer
this computer over here that i use for
editing and stuff i think today
i've been [ __ ] around with that all
day trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
wrong with that thing
god [ __ ] gary in there asked me to do
the btk voice how did this [ __ ] you
haven't done that in a while how did i
make it so famous for doing bdk because
you're good at it i mean he's back there
right i see a little i see him and i see
little hh homes up there too you have to
first of all if you have to [ __ ] take
your lips and you have to go like this
yeah you have to make that face to make
a face
okay
you know
well you know
i'm surprised btk didn't even like uh
weigh in on the whole zodiac thing yeah
did he yeah well btk would come in and
stay like
yeah
he could make a cipher but he couldn't
spell
that's true yeah he'd be like that
he'd be like
yeah i remember getting on that because
i'm like i'm totally absolutely gonna
judge you because i can't even [ __ ]
you know what he was doing he just had
his little wheels and his rod and all
the and all the little symbols and
he was [ __ ] up and he was making
mistakes you can see how he misspelled
stuff and he made mistakes and he didn't
even go back and correct him because he
didn't even notice he he's not as smart
as he
pretended that he was
it's easy to fool the cops you know
that's all it is
well in some ways it is i mean look how
long it took him to catch btk yeah and
the only reason they caught him is
because he just couldn't stand it
anymore and he had to like start
taunting them again so they found out
where he was he wasn't he wasn't an
upstanding citizen or anything
but not
not like dennis yeah what did well
i was good for the community yeah yeah
went to church raise the family you know
what you're supposed to
killed people's dogs
made a mother grass
well that's just me you know
you gotta enforce regulations got
enforced regulations you can't have all
these dogs running around you can't have
all these women running around with
their skirts and stuff just
somebody's gotta
keep all that in check
you know what's going to happen and
somebody's going to do something about
it one way or the other so it might as
well be me
[Laughter]
that's probably exactly how he was
thinking of course although like i said
i think i mentioned this on the zodiac
show that book that um i think like
sophie sent it to me right the uh about
the about btk
and um
[Music]
that dude
just the way his mind works is
baffling i mean it's not baffling like
you can kind of understand it but yeah
like you reading it you're just like oh
my god this dude is like [ __ ] insane
all right let's grab this back in if
grab is back in i'll [ __ ] answer your
question because i'm just sitting around
here gary lennon says one more question
what do you guys drink i'm on the beer
this is actually this is a screwdriver
right here yeah it's just vodka orange
and i got a tequila sunrise with sand
using sam's silver tequila which i've
told you guys earlier you can't tell a
[ __ ] sam
silver from [ __ ] milagro silver
that's good
even comes in a damn fancy bottle
for 20 bucks you get big
fancy
yeah grubs is here all right grandpa's
here
so he can get back you can get back get
back to this
oh my god that's what you should call
your channel manly answering man manly
ass astrid
family ass answering
them
if mgtow dudes for some reason i don't
understand why mgtow dude want to
attract women because if they're mgtow
they don't want to attract women right
maybe they get off on telling women to
go away yeah women have been doing that
for centuries
yeah that's the same thing we don't we
don't feel bad about it they don't feel
bad about it so
[Laughter]
how you do that is um you get jacked
that's how you do it
um
in my experience having been [ __ ] in
good condition to regular condition and
this and that and then to [ __ ] pretty
good condition
um
being jacked [ __ ] attracts a lot of
attention from women they respect it
because it looks like you have
discipline you're in good shape you look
virile and it doesn't matter what what
you what how old you are
because it appeals it's going to appeal
to
whatever women of the age group you that
you're that you are i guess you say
um
being jacked is uh the male equivalent
of some chick having big ass implants
like jenny
be like that
um
like i gotta say if i uh going out the
bike or bar those
bartenders think i'm a stripper they had
to talk them out of that i said no i'm
not a stripper
you should have totally rolled your line
that would have been so so funny so now
you could have made up like a whole
persona they were like how hilarious
would that have been you're like you
could have like made up a whole stripper
name i know and a whole you you know you
could have like said you'd like dress up
in a fireman's outfit or some [ __ ] like
that like that's kind of like basic but
you could have come up with something
like that and he was like no you're not
is it not just she's like what's your
what's your only fans
[Laughter]
so i don't have only fans
and says you got only fans and she's
like no
and i says you got only fans
no
so you got only fans don't you
no no yeah he said i didn't believe her
she got only fans
gary lennon says can can you donate
through paypal yes yes you can um
i don't should i put my should i put my
email address in the chat i don't think
anyone's gonna like harass me or
anything yeah my paypal i'm gonna put my
paypal right here uh what my paypal
account is
and
if you want to give me some money
through paypal little [ __ ] that would be
really awesome that's it right there
um but yeah
so
i do cash app too but i don't i don't
even remember like what my name is on
that because i only have that for
i only got that because i had one client
that didn't
couldn't use paypal for whatever reason
and had to use cash app
but
yeah so i put it in there grant jumps in
says some manly dudes act like they hate
women as a way to attract women uh they
might have some dudes like that but
that's not how that's not a good
strategy
no not at all
unless you want to attract some chicks
that are like really weird yeah consider
really self-hating or something well
you'd end up attracting some chicks that
are kind of like [ __ ] sonia or
something yet i mean they're [ __ ]
like attracted to abusive relationships
they do that's what i'm saying like
you're gonna attract women with uh
issues right with self-esteem issues or
some kind of like yeah you're gonna
attract some people like that women tend
to be attracted to guys who [ __ ] have
uh their own thing going on and they
have their own interests and they're
pursuing them and they then they're real
competent in what they're doing and
they're not these dudes are not bending
over backwards chasing
women because they're not desperate
that that's they like guys who are have
a project well i mean nobody likes
desperate no people comes off looking
like desperate yeah nobody likes people
being desperate or super needy or
anything like that
everybody i mean everybody likes people
who are like kind of confident or like
you said you know they they have their
own thing going on they don't need you
to like oh please meet all my needs type
of thing because that's nobody wants
that kind of
situation
at that [ __ ] biker bar that i [ __ ]
posted you got girls that [ __ ] work
there and they're all in her 40s they'll
see dudes and they know a desperate
sucker and they'll [ __ ] try to get
tips and [ __ ]
and and
they know what they know a shop when
they see him
well yeah and they don't and they don't
[ __ ] really respect those dudes per
se it's just
they'll entertain them for some cash and
they're like oh you get the [ __ ] out
it's like a rube it's like something
you'd see out of a carnival yeah it's
exactly like that well and you know you
don't play into that [ __ ]
and i mean that happens a lot you get
that a lot because we've known uh women
that were strippers and things like that
and it's the same kind of thing it's
like they can see a dude like that
coming a mile away
and knowing you're gonna get a bunch of
money out of them right and the the
reason why
they see it coming
i see it coming
the dudes are approaching the woman and
they're not looking at her like she's a
person
they're looking at her like she's
like another species or a product or
something
uh they're not trying to be friendly and
make any kind of personal contact
with with with her or anything it's not
personal it's you can just see it
there's just a certain well that's what
i mean and i kind of feel like that's
well that's the issue with like the way
a lot of dudes like that like approach
women and women can tell it's like
you're approaching
them like
oh well if i buy her enough drinks like
or if i buy her things or something like
that then she'll you know if i put in
money sex will come out yeah exactly
exactly and it's and it and it's not
about her it's just about oh well she's
sex she's attractive to me so therefore
you know i mean
you're not interested in her as a person
and what's funny is that you look at the
dudes and even as even as a guy i see it
[ __ ] coming a mile away they're not
macho they're very beta
they're not they're not alpha at all
they're
they're beta they're beta dudes
they don't know any women they don't
even have any female friends
and that's kind of always a red flag
it's like it's always going to be kind
of like that's kind of how you know a
good dude is if they have female friends
that they're not interested in banging
or they don't or they just like that
person as a person yeah you know what i
mean that's like they're not just
friends with them because they think
they're hot and maybe i'll get to banger
or something yeah
because
see that's the thing and and honestly
that's it kind of works both ways you
don't want to
befriend anybody or anything like that
with ulterior motives like that you know
what i mean
yeah now that's the [ __ ] beta klinger
on i'm a nice guy but you look you can
see right through and go no you just
want the ass that's another thing they
got dudes who are those betas
but they don't want to appear as that
beta so they try to be sensitive in this
clingy but no you're a [ __ ] vampire
basically what what those dudes are is
they're like the remore that's swimming
up next to the shark's mouth that's what
it is that's where those dudes are
there's lots of those
yeah there's little remora fish and it
really even though and that women's that
women cease to do that too it manifests
in a different way yeah but it's
you know in practice it's the same thing
yeah uh this is a this is a dude that is
not seeing you as a person
right they're just seeing you as a
source as a source of [ __ ] that's
basically which they did don't get
right and that's the reason they don't
get it
because they don't you know what i mean
so that's why i think it's good like
sometimes when i you know when i used to
talk to guys before and they'd be like
you know i don't really know where to
meet women or something like that i'm
like why don't why don't you not worry
about
the the end goal it's like why don't you
go out and do stuff you like that's like
interesting to you and in the course of
doing that you might actually meet
someone that's into the same [ __ ] as you
yeah
and maybe that will work out better in
your favor rather than just like going
somewhere and trying to pick up chicks
that don't have anything
look at the chick picker-uppers
women all seem to be vying
for that same top ten percent of the men
constantly
um but the problem is is that all 100
percent of the men are vying for the
[ __ ] top 10 percent of the women
so they don't understand why they're not
getting that it's like dude
your middle echelon or maybe the lower
end of middle echelon how are you going
to stack up and get this
top ten percent of the woman that's all
you're gunning for you'll never get that
never
those top ten percent of the guy
those top ten percent of the women are
going for guys there's something about
them either they have a whole bunch of
money or they look [ __ ] fantastic or
they're [ __ ] cute
and a mixture of all that
if you're it has to do with what age
what age group you're talking about it's
a system it's definitely a system you
can predict it
but they won't lower their sights to
something realistic see that's the thing
that [ __ ] blows my mind
well i got friends there like this i'm
not talking about people as if it's
alien we got friends i'm not gonna name
any names
who maybe they were a [ __ ] seven or
an eight back in the day but dude is now
a five
okay and he's still running after these
set eights and nines on these females
and they're [ __ ] 15 years younger
than him and it's just that's just he's
not in that game anymore but they just
can't
they can't adjust to reality
well i mean that's kind of like an
offshoot of just seeing a woman as yeah
an object essentially or like as a piece
of ass you're not just a real personal
relationship right yeah
there's like well they look good so
therefore i'm going after that right so
they don't really care if they have
anything else in common with them
it's just i don't know that's stupid
but um don't
don't believe what your mom told you
you're not pretty
all right the world is not round and
nothing's flat nothing is fair the world
is [ __ ] flat
they're judging you by appearance first
that just that's just the way it is 90
of people are like that
and if you don't look good you're just
not gonna get any action
you just have to look as good as you can
and uh
it's gonna take work
if it doesn't take work then that means
you're not gonna get that top 10 20 it's
just it's just that's not how the game
works you're going to have to go back
with somebody who looks like you and
that may not be acceptable to you
because these same dudes that i'm
telling you
that are going well i wouldn't go out
with her and i'm [ __ ] looking at her
and i'm looking and goes yeah but she's
kind of better looking than you are
you would grow her she's [ __ ] better
look at you
okay
[Laughter]
well as i said it's like it's you know
everybody doesn't have to look like a
supermodel but you at least have to look
like you have to look like the person
you're going after going after well and
you have to look like you made an effort
you can't look like you just like rolled
out of bed with like crusty ass
underwear on or some [ __ ] like that yeah
and like going out with stains down your
front like t-shirt and stuff and then
you're like expecting to to score with
some hot chick it has to be within your
league
yeah yeah
you know
and i know guys that are just will not
go out with women that would that are in
their league so therefore they don't get
anything
dj maniac says it's in cell friday it's
not friday i feel like we have this
conversation every week we probably do
you sell friday zach says so what i
meant to take away from this lecture is
tom is a flat earther
they heard this flat
everything they told you everything that
told you that sounds right and real nice
is a lie it's actually the truth is that
the earth is flat
not literally hear this flat and that
[ __ ] everything that's wrong and bad
that's actually what it is that's that's
reality
well it's not we don't live in a denied
an idealistic world well no but we don't
live in a hellscape either well
depending on it's not a hellscape it's
just reality and reality is people are
selfish and people are damned
superficial and people um
are about getting uh getting uh moving
ahead
and you do that by you know
being an evil hairless monkey you know
going out with people that
do something for you and that it's it
works out and at least it's a mutual
thing that's another thing
that's not so much of an evil hairless
monkey things
when i talk about the evil hairless
monkeys
at a minimum there must be reciprocation
you give something you get something
back reciprocation
that's very simian very monkey-like
there is no
one way
like piss-stained
broke-ass bums do not get hot women they
just don't that's not going to be in
that's a controversial thing yeah
and the [ __ ] you know the the the the
tenderness of some woman's heart oh i'ma
[ __ ] blow this [ __ ] all day
no you're not no you're not that's a
[ __ ] bum he hasn't changed his
underwear and weeks [ __ ] pissing down
his legs and drinking isopropyl alcohol
from [ __ ] from [ __ ] perry
drugstore you know this just stop it
stop it
drinking some sterno drink is stirring
mike bird says challenge accepted tom
yeah go ahead suck it dude i kind of i
feel like that would be something they
would do on jackass yeah
yeah
did they do that i kind of feel like
they did something like that [ __ ] oh
what's his name
drink all that damn bull sperm
see i couldn't watch that he drank that
through it right up
well yeah because how do you feel this
man i feel [ __ ] really dirty because
what would your dad say
he was like yeah
yeah what up what those dudes i wonder
if this dude's parents like actually did
they watch that show
isn't that funny yeah they look at all
that [ __ ] and just [ __ ] laugh yeah
david june says tom i drink cough syrup
and get all the homeless [ __ ]
look at pogie what did you do you fall
asleep what is she doing is she back
she's on her back hold on her back come
down here and pet me oh my god she's so
funny
every now and then like i turn around
and she's just like laying in the middle
of the floor like
laying on her back with her little belly
sticking out
she's so weird yeah
uh
zach says i know okay by the way i
watched cloot again last night what are
you guys going to cover we are i swear
um i'll try to do it this week i want to
do
well we're going to do identity because
uh rob sent us that
and i want to go see
nightmare alley
yeah um but then maybe we can do clute
as well
yeah pookie's laying back there i wish i
wish i could like pick the camera up and
like show cause she's just like laying
back there going like what
i was trying to get her because she's
got like those little scrunchy balls and
i was trying to get like because
sometimes she'll have one and one paw
like when she's laying on her back and
like have it hold it like that and i was
trying to get her to like hold two of
them that were the same colors they'd
look like pom-poms but she didn't know
what i was trying to do now
graham said there was a guy tom and i
went to high school with name roger d
who treated women like dirk and they
always came back for more trying to
think of who that was
roger d
trying to remember
trying to remember that
i don't know
i wasn't there if you remind me the last
name [ __ ] i'll remember who it was is
that
is that that dark-haired dude did real
fair skin [ __ ] was on steroids back
in [ __ ] high school [ __ ] got
huge i think that's the same dude you're
talking about
uh what was his name
roger
and
he was going out with them fine ass kind
of [ __ ] cheerleader types i think
that's who you talk about there's one of
dave viola's friends i think as he
talked about it's hard to extrapolate
though like with teenagers because
i kind of feel like
i don't know i i knew like a lot of
teenage like when i was a teenager like
a lot of the teenage girls that just
like went out with these horrible
horrible dudes and then like you know
years later they were just like what the
[ __ ] was i even thinking i was so
[ __ ] stupid yeah that was the one
dixon was listening okay yeah i vaguely
remember that guy or vaguely remember
that guy
zach said the double take i did when you
said your cat had little scrunchy balls
she's a female cookie doesn't have balls
she's a little girl but um
no she's got a little
little paper
balls that you don't go
and then when you pick them up because i
pick up one in each hand and i'm like
she turns around like oh yeah and then
like you throw them and she kind of like
she likes to wave them around okay grab
this [ __ ] bringing it back oh pat
we used to call him matrix what's up
patrick
his dad his dad [ __ ] mandrake
get to get the [ __ ] out of here patrick
his one time we came in his dad was so
[ __ ] up his dad was [ __ ] drink
drunk on the [ __ ] ground
[ __ ] drunk drinking canadian mist and
his wife was leaving him that was pat's
mom
and he and and [ __ ] her name was
patty
and he was and and [ __ ] he got up off
the [ __ ] ground and me and steve and
pat were there and he's like
andrew where the hell is your mother and
he's like get down there get laid back
then on the couch she's like [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
patrick and he goes patty where are you
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you're working
i called her a horse and she wasn't in
there actually she was she goes [ __ ] you
pat [ __ ] you
yeah i mean
what was it [ __ ] you colleen that's what
his name was he was from us he was from
uh
he was from um
estonia he was the estonians and he's
like [ __ ] [ __ ] you collie she wasn't
from an estonian that he was
that was [ __ ] wild man you're
bringing back memories of this [ __ ] dude
and then [ __ ] patrick
patrick was [ __ ] screwing this girl
and i think her name was patty it was
the [ __ ] principal's daughter
remember her she was fine as hell
fine as hell
and
boy he didn't deserve that one i think
her name was patty
right you can regret correct me if i
wanna anyway she was [ __ ] fine
and uh
he [ __ ] that up she got mad so she
[ __ ] steve to get to get even with her
that was [ __ ] that was the [ __ ] my mind
was blowing at that time it was like
[ __ ] i walked in i walked into
steve's house and [ __ ] knock on the
door for his rumors come on man open the
[ __ ] door hold on i got somebody in
here man hold on man i got a guess man i
got a guest so you gotta guess he's in
his mom's house you know this is right
we're in high school so what do you mean
you got guests
come on baby
hold on a minute i'll be out in a minute
i'm going oh he's got a woman in here
tough yeah because it takes about
so i waited 10 minutes i'm out there
smoking justin running around and [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] door up opens up and she
comes walking out and sauntering out
[ __ ] you know the [ __ ]
swishing and [ __ ]
and i was just my mind was blown i was
like man i was like that was patrick's
girlfriend and the [ __ ] i looked at
steve and we were locking eyes and i'm
like he dog you and he's [ __ ] give me
the wink eye like yeah and [ __ ] she
went off and i had to go get the whole
skinny
and she's like yeah she just broke up
with patrick and that says so you hit
we didn't use those words back then we
didn't have this so you you [ __ ] it
and he's like
of course
but
of course and i was like like she's
getting even and he's like she's like
yeah yeah yeah she got you she got you
that was that was those were the days
man it was a big deal back then you see
it today you'd be like yeah whatever but
let's see
you [ __ ] his girlfriend no
he was cute
gary lennon says come on tom need to see
the wig it's on my paypal donation
all right all right which one did you
have like one particular one of mine
straight off straight i'm gonna go
straight [ __ ] clan dancing
uh david genes jenny if you covered the
man from torrid i haven't that's another
one i haven't done i don't think i've
done that one man from that's another
one that i've been wanting to do but i
haven't gotten around to it so i'm
writing this all i'm writing all this
down writing all this down i mean the
show we're doing next week we're gonna
have to do
that'll be the christmas special because
next week's [ __ ] christmas man
already
it's kind of crooked i'm gonna fix it
i'll fix it
no wig and btk voice
he has to do btk
oh you know
yeah it's it's kind of weird seeing like
looking like glenn danzig or the dude
from death clock or whatever and then
like by talking like btk you're [ __ ]
what are you doing man i can't see it
you're pulling the thing like way in the
wrong direction there you go yeah i feel
it now he's like he's like pulling the
part like way over here
[Applause]
i feel like you need a beard yeah like a
like a pointy beard
kind of like a little yeah yeah like
like a long like devil ebay
thank you
thank you zach a show on autism would be
fascinating if you ask me yeah actually
that would be probably pretty cool
yeah and the wigs are on so he says yeah
oh [ __ ] it he gave me the name leaply
that's right man
yeah
yeah he's a muslim head friend of viola
yeah yep i'm really talking about that's
back in the [ __ ] high school days
he needs the btk mustache says gary yeah
this shit's [ __ ] so hot
you just started he's like yeah he's
worn the wig for like less than five
minutes it's always hot no i just know
it's a hot wig i'm not hot right now but
it takes a while after about after about
an hour it's stressful because like i
said i've worn the wig like oh we're
just [ __ ] to the club or yeah because i
wear wigs to the club all the time and
it's like you don't hear me like pissing
me down look at this
i'll show it with hair and they're like
[Laughter]
i don't take it it's just serious i i
i'm the kind of guy that i'd be on the
dance floor taking it off well yeah my
hair off yeah taking his hair hair off
scratch my head and then put it back on
[Laughter]
i'm not trying to i'm not trying to fool
anybody
well i mean it's easier for you too
because you don't have any hair so you
can it's easy for you to like take it
off and put it back on yeah like when i
cuz if i wear a wig i have to put like a
wig cap over the hair
you know what i mean so it's kind of
like a bigger deal and plus i have to
like kind of clip it in there too
otherwise it slides around
so you know it's it's a whole other deal
but uh
tom is visibly upset um
what am i upset about well i don't know
if they were talking about like btk like
talking about how
house people ripped that i don't
remember like btk stuff
i told her i'd have to kill her she of
course she was upset she got outside she
was upset yeah yeah that like blew my
[ __ ] mind that he said that yeah she
was uh upset gave her some water imagine
that yeah
just the way he said it
the way he said it implied that it was
like not um
not an understandable reaction to have
uh no i think he thought it was
understandable but he it was unthinkable
that he wouldn't do it right yeah well i
have to
that's what i do
yeah that's his thinking well i just
have a sexual thing and you're just
gonna have you have to die you know yeah
and it's just like oh well here here's
some water to make you feel better
that's like that just like [ __ ] blows
my mind things like that
somebody thinks like that
that's another thing where he's just
like basically seeing and this is the
weird thing too like where
i mean he compartmentalized big time uh
he didn't call it that uh what did he
call it he called it um cubic cubing he
cubed it cubed another cube yeah um
because you know he had a wife and kids
and everything like that and i don't
think he would have done anything to
them necessarily
um because he actually saw them as
people but everybody else he really
didn't seem to see as people yeah like
everybody else was just like um
you know that's just a thing i can use
for my sexual gratification yeah gary's
laughing he just says tom
i don't know what you talking about
there's no there's no [ __ ] uh context
there bro
well you're just funny and i'm just
funny i guess maybe
um
oh so what was oh what i was gonna say
was that yesterday we had the
uh house inspector yeah came well we had
we had one come today too
oh really is that what that was yeah for
[ __ ] he was just looking for
uh termite infestations there aren't
none of course which we know but we have
to get it checked that was only 120
bucks for that yeah okay
just gotta [ __ ] yeah yesterday's
inspections yesterday the guy came he
was here for three hours right like more
than three hours yeah the house is
stable he was up in the attic and he
gets dead the house is sound he says the
house is in good shape
yeah it's like there's i think there's a
couple little things but nothing yeah
he's that big of a video he said it's
just just maintenance stuff
just regular just regular maintenance
because how old is this house i feel
like this 15. oh okay
so it's actually like about the same age
as our
12 to 15 i think oh okay
gary says uh where are you in america
are you asking us where in florida
central florida yeah
you were in eustis
yeah
not that far from orlando orlando
yeah
uh zach says ooh the house inspector
came
that's just one of them it was a porno
movie yeah everybody has to buy their
own inspectors
no va's gonna have their inspectors and
then the [ __ ] seller is gonna come
and then they're gonna appraise the
house and it's gonna be appraised by two
different two different independent
people and
then we'll see we'll see it should
everything should be closed next month
halfway through next month
yeah i'm hoping so
should be
it should it should go all right yeah
they're trying to negotiate with the
closing costs and uh
we'll see i don't think there's going to
be any problems
it should close should close fine
um and um
some i'm gonna try to rig it up where a
lot of the
costs
that we just did and the closing costs
can be refactored into the financing
you know right yeah
that way
it's not a lot of stuff out of pocket
and then um yeah that would be good
right so and
i may be able to finance it for more
than what it's actually worth which
would be kind of like taking a loan out
on it right
so we could do that and [ __ ] do
something and i'm gonna try to hook it
up to where
the first mortgage payment might be
more than 30 days away maybe 60 days
away so that way we can get an extra pay
period behind us yeah so be like
skipping a month
until the payments start
be nice huh yeah that would be nice so i
think i think uh they said that they
might be able to do something like that
we'll see
grampa's hammer says btk's daughter
carrie lives in the orlando area yeah
i've heard that yeah perhaps you can
invite her to the oasis for some day
drinking yeah with the local charmers
oh my god
yeah i heard she lived around here i
wouldn't want to you know it's like i
don't bother i wouldn't bother though
because it's like can you imagine i just
can't imagine
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what i mean
it's you know if my it if it turned out
that my dad was a serial killer
um
you know you would never hear the
[ __ ] end of it i would have to like
[ __ ] go in the witness protection
program i don't want to deal with that
[ __ ] [ __ ] all the time where's
tila's teal up in his [ __ ] i
don't say yeah i don't see her all right
go ahead and drop any quest this is open
lines friday if you guys have any
questions if you want to talk about
anything go ahead and uh
no need for me too says i could float
you alone but you'd have to use jenny as
collateral yeah
you'd be tearing that [ __ ] up man
i had to get that [ __ ] repaired hey i'm
here too you know
i ain't pimping her out
[Laughter]
well gee thanks i'm not gonna do that
like it even needed to be safe
[Laughter]
yeah i don't think tila was here uh
wednesday night either was she uh no she
was here last week though yeah she was
here last friday yeah
well yeah and it might be like people
getting home from work and stuff and
plus it's getting to be
the holidays [ __ ] man next friday is
christmas eve yeah so we're gonna have
to do we're gonna have to do the
christmas eve man i gotta start thoughts
so i'm gonna start thawing out those
turkeys
oh we're doing turkeys again yeah we're
gonna do a turkey i got two turkeys but
we're gonna only cook one of them
because turkeys were on sale so i'm
gonna be tuning in [ __ ]
but uh we're gonna get a turkey i got a
turkey and a spiral cut ham well [ __ ]
yeah man all right so we're gonna
christmas the [ __ ] out yeah gotta make
some more um
[ __ ]
uh stuffing
yeah i'm not gonna get all that fancy
but you know we'll see
yeah christmas i usually i mean you know
it's i like having turkey i like more
than anything at christmas time i like
to have like christmas cookies yeah i
like christmas cookies yeah i i saw this
one program this british dude he
couldn't understand he's like why are
you having thanksgiving dinner because
that spoils your christmas dinner and
i'm like man [ __ ] out well no no well
they don't do that well that's what they
don't do that over there
i mean that's kind of their big because
thing is christmas because it's a long
period of time between [ __ ]
thanksgiving well it's a month it's a
month well that foils no it doesn't i
could eat [ __ ] thanksgiving once a
month
yeah i really i really like that well
the thing about it is that i think we
talked about this before but like you
know thanksgiving dinner is much more
not everybody eats the same thing but i
feel like the majority of people yeah
like like 90 of people in america eat
pretty much the same stuff for
thanksgiving whereas christmas is kind
of all over the place yeah christmas can
be anything like a lot of people will do
like a big meal but they don't
necessarily do turkey a lot of people do
ham or they do
italians italians do lasagna yeah or
they do a big lasagna or something like
that mexicans do tamales yeah you know
it's just something like big and special
right whatever your ethnic [ __ ] food
is that's what you have for christmas
yeah so yeah so christmas i mean i feel
like as many people's houses i've been
to over christmas
it's you know it varies wildly depending
on where you grew up and
turkey and stuffing terrific and stuff
is british
anglo that's british
irish scottish welsh it's you know it's
uk based
you know that's that's what that is
that's a that's a that's a germanic
white people type things the germans
would eat some [ __ ] like that too they
[ __ ] would love that
they probably have that
um if not they definitely have that
spiral cut ham
because you know germans eat swine they
[ __ ] love that [ __ ]
yeah when we i mean when i was growing
up for christmas we usually we always
had turkey for thanksgiving but for
christmas we hardly ever made turkey
yeah we always had ham yeah well among
other things but that was like the main
meal we always had a hand every and
sometimes people would would bring like
they'd make like spicy meatballs or
um you know we had like a lot of kind of
side
dish type stuff but it was like all kind
of all over the i think
technically i mean we do a shrimp ring
like you know people would have like a
bunch of boiled shrimp i think
technically
if you actually went by the book
um
anglo-american christmas dinner is
probably ham
i don't think it's turkey
we just do it because there's
thanksgiving because it's after
thanksgiving and you can buy a bunch of
turkeys
honestly i like i like ham but
i wouldn't mind having turkey for
thanksgiving and turkey for christmas i
can do them both yeah that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna have
we're gonna have it for christmas also
i mean
my dad's side of the family we usually
just did a spiral cut ham and a bunch of
sides my mom's side of the family which
is much larger because my mom has like
seven brothers and sisters who all had
you know their own families uh they
would generally do a ham and a turkey
yeah and a whole bunch of other stuff
because there was like a hundred people
now up in michigan over there where
grafters at all those [ __ ] pollocks
and slobs and [ __ ] their christmas
didn't their christmas dinner's [ __ ]
it's going to be
something like paprikash
gosh that's a very [ __ ] thanksgiving
paprika pierogies
um that's all right that sounds that
sounds good actually
i make paprika chicken paprika on the
[ __ ] bone man it's just good man yeah
we last time you made it was a couple
months ago a couple months back but yeah
[ __ ] with that hungarian paprika
and you're [ __ ] cooking it and
basically sour cream man it's just
fattening but it is good it is very and
it's got to be hot like chili
you put it
they're going to put it on egg noodles
but i actually like it on
rice or mashed potatoes yeah i'm not
really i don't really like egg noodles
that much
i mean it's good like that yes but i
like mashed potatoes yeah i like
pierogies though too
yeah cheeseburgers yeah
[ __ ] yeah
oracle says i bake snickerdoodles
it's like that's one thing i kind of you
know i don't know i kind of want to like
i don't know if i want to bake christmas
cookies maybe i'll just go buy some
graham says
polish eat head cheese yeah oh no they
had cheese in mississippi [ __ ] love
had cheese
yeah i'm pretty sure like my
grandparents ate head cheese and they
were in tennessee
yeah i like that [ __ ] um cajun head
cheese eat that in mississippi some
people go what the [ __ ] is head cheese
you can take a
pork head
and other kind of things that you
normally wouldn't eat you just cook it
down cook it off the bone take it you
make a bunch of little scraps like
scrapple
and then you mix it with a bunch of
things and you make it almost kind of
like a baloney and it comes in a loaf
like a meatloaf and you cook it and you
slice it and you can uh eat it on bread
it's [ __ ] great it's if it's spiced
right it's got kind of gelatin it's
there's gelatin in it you know what i
mean it's kind of a gelatinous a little
bit
not all that much but
it's almost kind of like aspic but it's
got little
pieces of pork in it it's good
if it's spiced right
real good on toast
make a sandwich out of it [ __ ] good
real good mayonnaise
need for me too says why the hell they
call it cheese ain't no cheese in it
yeah i don't really know there's no
cheese in there no there's not it's i
mean it's head for sure yeah it's more
like meatloaf
but head loaf doesn't quite sound right
it doesn't sound the same
i mean head cheese doesn't sound that
great either but i mean that might sound
even grosser because that kind of sounds
like toe cheese but yeah
head loaf and cheese
look at that loaf
that's it i need a cookie channel we got
a cooked book man
we did for a little while we did um a
little show called on the menu but i
think we only did like
seven or eight of them and then like we
just stopped doing it well really you
know what i mean
unless you're going to talk about
specific dishes you'll run out of [ __ ]
to talk about that's true
i talked about things that were like in
general how to do certain things in
general
yeah he did a pizza show we did a sauce
show we did a bunch of
ones
talk about them other sauces yeah
more like just an
introductory thing to [ __ ] get people
to push people down into the culinary
arts
but yeah gary we did we did do a
cookbook like a while back you can find
it it's got all kinds of good stuff
mexican stuff how to make tortillas
it's got
southern food uh brazilian food
um chinese fast food how that stuff's
made indian food indian food that's
indian food we make indian food a lot
actually so it's mostly comfort food
[ __ ] that you would buy i'll talk about
how to make that
and then i'll talk about some southern
classics like [ __ ] [ __ ] that elvis
used to eat
[Laughter]
like fool's gold and elvis would eat
fool's gold
which was a big old [ __ ] italian loaf
bread
slathered in butter
cut in half
with a whole jar of [ __ ] peanut
butter and a whole jar of [ __ ] grape
jelly and a whole bunch of fried bacon
on it
and if i could he would pay a hundred
dollars for that from his chef
at this restaurant down in nashville and
only a fool would eat that so it's
called fool's gold
plus and only a fool would pay a hundred
dollars
but he had a hundred dollars he had that
kind of money i mean you're rich as
elvis 100 is like a buck yeah so which
is crazy to think about yeah
but
i don't know i like peanut butter and
jelly sandwich as much as the next
person
but
yeah man where's sandra
oh yeah i don't know
yeah she was here wednesday i think
but
yeah oracle says i'm making uh chicken
adobo the filipino kind for dinner
sunday that sounds good actually
yeah
so we're just going to do turkey and ham
for christmas
maybe i'll get some cookies like i said
i don't feel like bacon anybody can say
he's never had gumbo i guess he's asking
if it's good yeah it's very good
gumbo you have to have something called
filet gumbo filet
which is the spice mix you can order it
online but make sure you have gumbo
filet
before you sassafras yes
spell file gumbo file but it's but it
has a it has a yeah it has a little case
get that
um
and that's the spice that you need for
gumba
you have to understand how to make a
roux
which is using butter to cook down a
bunch of
damn flour to make it very dark
it's like a dark thickening agent
and then you have to learn how to
cook okra and allow the [ __ ] starch
to release from the ochre and separate
the starch from the ochre so you have
[ __ ] okra slices
you got because they okra when you cook
it will release a bunch of slime
so you can't have that in the damn
gumbo you have to you have to cook the
oprah's okra separate and separate it
from that slime
once the slime is released you can then
use the ochre and add it in there
you're going to want to put chicken in
it and sausage
and if you can afford shrimp you do that
too or or blue crabs there's a bunch of
recipes for it
and you're going to want that on [ __ ]
long grain white rice
i like it on [ __ ] basmati on basmati
rice
or indian rice i think it's really good
on that
but any kind of rice as long as it's not
a sticky rice that's and it's got to be
white
but it's just a um
it's a stew
it's kind of a thick stew with
chicken and
gumbo and
sausage or shrimp with or whole [ __ ]
blue crabs depends on how messy you want
to get
blue crabs yeah a lot of gumbo has a
mixture of all that
for flavor
uh some people aren't used to picking up
a damn crab out of their bowl and
[ __ ] start tearing it apart and
throwing and getting the meat out of a
[ __ ] little bitty blue crab um
but you know we were doing it
the main thing though is to release
crab flavoring into the [ __ ] gumbo
although it doesn't have to be in there
shrimp excuse me chicken gumbo is good
enough
and in mexico it'd be real easy
to execute chicken gumbo
and it's just a
an africanized
french
louisiana
stew
it's good real good
it's within the mexican flavor palette
uh but it's also within the arabic
flavor palette arabs would like that
also there's a lot of arabic food that
kind of tastes like that
although
they would have to stick with chicken
you would they would or if they put if
they put
because we have some arabic listeners if
you put sausage in there of course it's
going to have to be halal so you're
going to be putting
beef sausage
beef sausage and shaken
it'll work
doesn't ha and i don't think i don't
think crabs are halal it's been a long
time i don't think they are
oh yeah i'm not sure i don't think so i
don't think they eat i don't think they
eat shellfish
yeah that's what i thought too i could
be wrong about that
i was just reading an article the other
day i had actually never heard of this
ever
but apparently there's a little bitty
tiny species of crab
that lives inside oysters
and that sometimes when you go to a
restaurant and get oysters sometimes
there's this little bitty little crabs
in there
and like when i guess they have a name i
can't remember what they're called a pea
crab or something like that like a
you know a little bit like size of a pea
yeah and um i guess you can eat them but
they're
i had never heard of that before but
they're like yeah that's kind of a thing
and
it's almost kind of like a little
delicacy or like oh it's kind of like
lucky when you get it because it's like
there's this little bitty crab that
lives in this [ __ ] probably wouldn't
taste like much well um
from what i've heard they said yeah
they're very small but they actually do
have like a really
like pretty not pungent but because that
sounds negative but a pretty strong like
crab flavor like even though they're
very small
um and you can eat them shell and all
because they're really really little but
i was like well i had never i never
heard of that
little tiny crabs living inside oysters
like so when you go and get like oysters
at a restaurant like every now and
there's little bitty crabs in there but
i guess i i don't know i kind of feel
like that should be wider uh
more widely dispersed information
because if you get oysters at a [ __ ]
restaurant or a bar or something you're
like oh my god there's bugs in it yeah
zack said he actually tried doing a
fool's gold type sandwich a few weeks
ago and he could feel the arteries
clogging after eating right yeah but was
it good
[Laughter]
yeah it's like that that could mean
either thing
and then mary's saying in gumbo alabama
and new orleans it's good jambulla i
don't know what jumbo jambalaya i don't
know what you talking about although
jambalaya is not gumbo there's dudes
there's two different things
jambalaya is more kind of like i mean
they're similar but they're not real
jambalaya is rice yeah
that's more kind of like um
like what do you call that biryani
indian biryani but it doesn't taste like
that but it's the same concept
man i suddenly wanted some like indian
food yeah khan says it sounds delicious
yeah it's good you'd like it
just make sure you order some gumbo
filet it's the little spice mix
yeah a bunch of different places here
make it like uh i think mccormick's
makes one and yeah
what's that other zadaran's shadow all
right zadaran's is the standard
that's the basic one because yeah that
one's that's more like new orleans yeah
and everybody has that
um
uh what was that i was gonna say sammy
tammy's asking if there's a recipe in my
book a recipe for what tammy i don't
hear you jambalaya i think i do have no
excuse me from gumbo i think they're
yeah there's a gumbo and jambalayan yeah
gumbo and jabba yeah yeah
dj maniac says they make a special
shampoo and a comb for that for those
little bitty crabs
the little crabs of the oysters
zach says well i probably used the wrong
bread i couldn't taste peanut butter and
the bacon i cooked in the microwave
because i'm a glassy [ __ ]
i don't cook bacon in the microwave dude
you can you can but that's not we used
to have one of those bacon cookers that
my grandma got off the off of the tv
yeah off the tv
yeah
and it works pretty good actually yeah
david says y'all making me hungry stop
it yeah yeah now it's like yeah i
started i started thinking about indian
food and i was like oh maybe if we go to
the movies tomorrow maybe i can go over
there's actually an indian a little
indian place in the mall across from the
called
i spice is that what it's called
spice meat or something like that dharma
up in england is talking about how they
have briony up there yeah chicken
biryani with a side of curry sauce my
favorite indian food in the uk yeah i
feel like i mean indian food is probably
way like way more uh prevalent in the uk
than here yeah
if you were to make jambalaya if you
make it right it's kind of like that but
it's it's a it's a cajun version the fl
the spice profile is different
um and there's a bunch of different
variations in jambalaya but it's a rice
ditch dish with uh chicken and sausage
in it and a bunch of spices it's good
like like a briyani
yeah it is very similar yeah i think of
all the indian foods i like biryani but
what's my i don't know
my favorite is probably um
man i really like your butter chicken is
really good
and i'm really also into sog paneer yeah
um
that's really good yeah and
memories of india which is like a really
good indian restaurant that we have here
like they have their lamb korma is just
like real good
yeah and it's like every time i go there
they have like an extensive menu and i'm
always kind of like man i should like
try something else but every time i go
i mean the lamb
the lamb korma is just so so good now
sometimes i get what's that other thing
i get i get um something with shrimp in
it too
uh that was shrimp what was that masala
masala yeah yeah um yeah with like the
curry leaves and stuff that's really
good but man their lamb korma is like
really really good slivered almonds and
yeah we haven't been in a while
and they give you just enough to where
if you eat it all you're just [ __ ]
you can't eat anymore yeah it's about 15
bucks a plate
but you can't eat any more
yeah because man they bring you like the
non and all the yeah the little [ __ ]
little [ __ ] what do you call little
little chip things i forgot what they're
called yeah
it's kind of like a little pringle
it's like a little pretty like a little
pringle
it's made out of it's made out of
[ __ ] um
uh
chickpeas not chickpeas what do you call
things lentils it's like ground up
lentils and
fried yeah yeah flat they make the
tournament flatten they fry i mean you
can like uh there's little chutneys you
can put on onion chutney i forgot what
they're called though
yeah hugo says i love lamb i do too and
you don't i mean you can buy it in the
u.s but it's not as widespread
um
you know if you go to a grocery store
it's like they'll have a couple packages
of lamb chops yeah and that's about it
i mean i feel like if you want to make
stuff with lamb you kind of have to go
to a butcher they don't really have it
in grocery stores not not to any great
extent
tammy says no tell me is saying no there
is a recipe in the book i don't know
what you're talking about baby jambalaya
and gumbo yeah it is in there yeah yeah
yeah well that's what she was saying she
said i'm saying that there was a recipe
because i think she has it yeah
um so yeah
mary connolly says i love eggplant
parmesan me too um honestly
i can eat italian food all day long i
can eat indian food all day long i like
just i just like food in general oracle
says shrimp and grits are delicious yeah
we do all kinds of grits
all kinds of grits dishes
cheese and grits with [ __ ] sausage
and eggs or whatever
now uh it's another place we haven't
been like the the place that's right
near mannequins
uh chantelle's yeah
they make excellent shrimp and grits you
can't get it in the middle of the night
because they have limited menu right but
if you go during the day they have like
really really good shampoo shrimp and
grits
you can get chicken and waffles in the
middle of talking about seafood yeti
which i i it's ringing the bell but i
can't really picture it
thank you zach what do you say in hawaii
they sold boxed lunches for five dollars
from this one place a ton of food korean
barbecue type [ __ ] oh my god some of the
best food i've had wish box lunches were
a bigger thing here you could make a
killing
yeah i kind of you don't really see that
all that much do you
which
strange
i mean you do i guess it's like fast
food type of place or maybe food trucks
do that kind of stuff yeah but
yeah not a lot of like restaurant
restaurants do it which is a little
strange
david june says grits aren't exactly
healthy but i like them
no they're not unhealthy either no more
than rice or anything else grits are
only unhealthy because of all the stuff
people put in yeah
because you put like because you put
like half a stick of butter in there
it's nothing more than just um
a blended up hominy yeah which is corn
yeah popcorn
it's all yeah so you know like i said i
it's kind of like one of those things
that
stuff a lot of stuff is only unhealthy
because of like [ __ ] that gets added
yeah they're putting
grease in there right
now in butter
which actually butter is nowhere near as
bad as people think it is vegetable oil
is worse than butter
but uh for you for your arteries the
worst of all would be bacon grease
yeah
bacon grease is the one that really gets
you and honestly growing up it's like
man you eat a lot of that we cooked
everything in baking bakery yeah you get
up and you'd get up in the morning that
was that's what your breakfast was
they'd fry eggs and bacon grease put the
bacon on there they even i think like
sometimes my grandparents would even
like make french toast in bacon grease
yeah
and then which is delicious
you're taking toast with jelly and
butter and then sopping up the bacon
grease on the plate along with the
[ __ ] egg yolk
which it's i love that guy i love that
stuff but it's not good for you i just
and i can't eat like that anymore like i
don't eat that regularly honestly i love
like big breakfasts that's one of the
things that i most look for but i can't
it i don't know it's all like an
ideation because i can't eat it
part of the reason why my dad has all
those stints in his heart and [ __ ]
his chest cut open is because when he
was a baby they put [ __ ] milk in the
bottle and then put into like [ __ ]
three or four tablespoons of [ __ ]
bacon grease
for your baby baby you got to have bacon
grease in the bottle and fat them up
keep them healthy
that's the one that's it's a very
southern thing that's like well yeah
because my grandmother was just like
that like sugar in it there you go
if you weren't eating or if you weren't
eating a lot
and she was skinny her whole life like
until she died she was very very thin
um so she could eat whatever she wanted
and not get fat because she's like super
lucky but you know the the rest of us
like when we were kids
you know if you weren't eating like two
or three helpings of something what's
the matter with you are you sick yeah
come on you need to like you you need to
eat something you're starving
back in the 70s and [ __ ] 70s and the 80s
when they were eating like that [ __ ]
heavy it started to trail off in the
modern era but back in the old days
eating like that
southern girls had that [ __ ] ellie
mae clamp it [ __ ] notoriety you know
what i mean they had [ __ ] they were
voluptuous i remember them
and it's because of that diet now they
were kind of like mexican girls too
they hit 20 and they were kind of fat
but when they were teenagers they ever
[ __ ] had nice big booty and [ __ ]
you know yeah you can get away with it
until you hit 20.
you start getting right
it catches up with you
right
so that's that's kind of how they were
ellie ellie mae had a lot of junk in the
trunk
[ __ ] you know hourglass figure
kind of like the uh
dolly parton would be the archetype
that's that's but she was not natural
dolly was
implants and plastic surgery and
chemicals and stuff from day one
which people used to bag on her but
dolly was a class act
she took
that southern look
to its [ __ ]
to its highest tech
level even back in the seventies and she
wasn't trying to hide it from anybody no
that's cheap i mean she was very open
about it
very open about and she just made a joke
about it yeah she's very open that it
was not natural which is why everybody
loves her to this day yeah she was she
wasn't trying to fool anybody no very
very sweet girl very sweet girl she
could sing man she could sing she's
pretty real pretty
zach says uh also i'm about to cook a
burger for dinner what should i put on
it fried egg uh fried egg bacon and
guacamole
yeah tomato that sounds like a good idea
yeah and a sprig of [ __ ] um
shake of that damn [ __ ]
um um el yakutano [ __ ]
brown [ __ ]
aztec hot sauce yeah you don't put that
[ __ ] on my burger brown stuff yeah oh
man i'll be getting heartburn in there
yeah it's just triple x on it
[ __ ]
super
super pornos
[Laughter]
fire
the best hot sauce and and i'm gonna go
ahead and confirm this guy who's got
kanavatsalan in the [ __ ] chat
straight from tijuana
he will tell you el ducatano is the best
corporate
hot sauce they have a bunch of different
flavors i like they and they have like
nine of them i've had them all
they even had like a um
a uh what's the little islands that they
have off the [ __ ] uh mediterra not
the mediterranean where they call them
the
[ __ ] out there around [ __ ] jamaica
and everything and
what do they call that caribbean
caribbean as in pirates of the yes the
pirates they had a [ __ ] yucatan has a
caribbean flavor that is [ __ ] great
too but they never have it at the
mexican store i had to i had to order it
directly from el ya katana
but that's that's good [ __ ] the green
jalapeno sauce is [ __ ] great the
red's pretty good
and then the brown will really [ __ ] you
up that's the good one that's the best
one the brown one and the green one and
the uh
and the
caribbean i think they had one that was
kind of yellow it was like a mustard if
i remember correctly i think it was yeah
that was good too or maybe that was
caribbean
i think caribbean was the yellow one
i don't remember the exact color
but uh though that that's the best hot
sauce best mexican hot sauce right there
i can't eat super hot stuff like i said
my stomach's just like well it's not
just the heat level it's the flavor
those flavors yeah it's really good well
that's what i mean that's it it bums me
out that i i can't really eat i mean i
can but i'll regret it like for a day or
two afterwards yeah yeah what i'm saying
that's right [ __ ] khan's correct me
it's yokoteco that's right oh yucca taco
it's not el yo katana you used to have
to go you used to have to drive well
actually it's not that far now but used
to drive to that little mexican grocery
store yeah which is actually only a
couple miles from our new house yeah
to stock up on that because
every now and then you can find the
brown one at walmart yeah but not like
sometimes it's hit or miss yeah cam guys
talking about that [ __ ] quadruple x
[ __ ] black hot sauce yeah that's what
i was telling there's a black one and a
brown one i've had them both
the black one's good too
and it's el yukateco
not ilya katano it's yucatan peninsula
but it's called
yucateco didn't somebody send you like a
big box of a whole lot yes yeah
i'm still not done with them yeah we've
still got some so
[Laughter]
they sent me a case of the brown one
yeah it's the x
tom puts hot sauce on pretty much
everything yeah i made a [ __ ] bean
burrito today if i could put some sauce
on it did you put some on mine because
it seemed kind of high okay no
because i was like no that was just a
regular
it had uh a little bit of uh uh
in the in those beans it had uh
onions a little bit of garlic
uh cumin and a little bit of chili
powder that was it that's the chili
powder
all right
so it wasn't like black beans yeah it
was a little bit hot but it wasn't it
wasn't all that hot
i can do a little bit hot but
like i said the older i get the
the more i'm getting i'm i'm turning one
of those old people that can only eat
stuff that's like all bland yeah
otherwise i have like really bad con
blossom says that that black habanero is
the hardcore use that's the vip stuff
yeah that's the one
i love that [ __ ]
dermot said i had tabasco sauce on my
pizza this evening
i was uh
i don't
that's louisiana hot sauce i grew up on
that too
tabasco is [ __ ] got too much of a
vinegar flavor to it for me
i actually like the other one the one
that was in the damn white
the white label on it
it's the competitor it's a lot cheaper
you guys might remind me about it but
[ __ ] we used to we used to have that
not crystals
that's actually more common in louisiana
mississippi was the one with the white
label it's just the the [ __ ] spent so
long the brands are eluding me now
um
but now uh [ __ ] tabasco that's
[ __ ] um
that's tourists yet
that's that's tourists the the it is
good but there's a better louisiana hot
sauce than that i'm just trying to
remember what was a white label red
lettering on it you guys will remind you
guys remember i'll figure it out i was
laughing because earlier on i've been
watching uh jade the libra is doing her
december
vlog
yeah and she was making her
they had some leftover pizza and she was
heating it up for dinner for her and her
husband
and the pizza she was giving her husband
she put ranch saw like ranch dressing
all over it i'm like pizza oh my god so
midwestern i forgot they're from kansas
city yeah that's some fun that is a
midwestern they put ranch on everything
i'm not averse to ranch dressing but
jesus christ ranch on pizza
and then i'm like looking at him going
how are you guys not fat
they're like they're thin and like how
do you get how do people eat pizza with
ranch dressing on it like every [ __ ]
day and they're not fat i don't
understand
they must have like really really they
must have really really good metabolism
i was right it's called crystal
yeah you said that crystal
yeah i'm trying to [ __ ] find a
picture of crystal
this is the one
this is the one i actually grew up with
yeah they still sell that one crystal
yeah everywhere crystal yeah and that is
like one-third or one-quarter of the
price of tabasco but better
tabasco like i said is kind of
that's kind of like the damn touristy
[ __ ] oh you [ __ ] up the lighting look
what you did you did it yep
you could get a little bottle of tabasco
a little bottle tabasco this big it'd be
like four dollars
you could get a huge bottle of crystal
for a dollar
and it would you know
don't don't play the game
[Laughter]
you go to louisiana they're [ __ ]
they're don't play big tabasco
i'm trying to get the lighting back to
how it was but yeah you [ __ ] it all up
you go to mississippi louisiana
louisiana they're we're having [ __ ]
crystal that's what's gonna be on the
table
not crystal meth that's a completely
different thing just crystal
yeah
david june said have you all ever
considered a listener tales episode just
a whole episode of stories people send
you of strange supernatural events that
happen well we did that for halloween i
think one year right yeah it took like
five hours it did well yeah we had
people like send us
i think we did it for halloween either
one year a couple years in a row um and
listeners sent in their ghost stories
that was actually pretty fun we maybe we
could do that again one of these days
man my drink's empty look at that i'll
get you one okay thank you
like this i feel like i have crystal so
yeah it is it is a little bit saltier
than um than uh tabasco and less
vinegary
but that's actually what we would eat
mary connolly says
martha stewart has a gathering on the
beach and has a clam boil or something
potatoes and clams or something boiled
on the beach yeah that's kind of like um
we've done that before not on the beach
obviously but we've done it with um
shrimp
and we didn't put clams in there but
crabs crab legs in there
and potatoes
and little short corn on the cobs
in a big huge
uh pot
with
crab boil
sauce in there and it's really really
good then you dump it all out on a table
and just like go to town
zach says uh if it says anything the
state dessert of indiana
is the sugar cream pie which tom might
like that sounds good actually
unhealthy as [ __ ] but so good yeah um
one of my favorite desserts growing up i
don't know if i could eat it nowadays
because probably be too sweet
but um
my grandma used to make gooey butter
cake and honestly i yeah i didn't know
like because when i was growing up
nobody else that i knew knew what it was
so i thought that that was just her
thing because she had the recipe from
her mom yeah from my great grandma it's
not what it sounds like
it's actually a lot better than it
sounds
it's it's super super sweet like we
would bug my grandma to make it
uh we'd bug her like start bugging
around thanksgiving
every now and then she'd break down and
make it for thanksgiving but usually
she's like no you have to wait till
christmas that's i'm only making it one
time a year and christmas is it
so she would make it but
it's super super rich
um
and honestly like it's kind of one of
those things that it has like
quote-unquote real ingredients but it
also has
um
you can use like boxed cake mix
yeah and mix it in with other stuff
and usually they just put kind of like
it's kind of thin it's more like a bar
actually it's not really a cake
it's it's a bar remember more than a
cake it's kind of like a cross treat a
donut and a damn um cinnamon roll but i
don't think it has cinnamon in it no it
doesn't honestly it's kind of like it
almost tastes a little bit i want to say
it almost tastes a little bit like
baklava
um
or it's in that same
yeah i mean baklava is completely
different i remember being surprised i
was like oh this is good it's very very
sweet and very very rich and you put
like powdered sugar on the top like um
but it's like i said it's not really
they call it gooey butter cake it's not
really a cake it's more like a bar it's
like a bar
cookie here's the southern classic for
y'all
and i believe that this is probably from
florida
key lime pie
isn't that from the florida keys yeah
yeah key lime pie
you need um
uh condensed milk sugar a bunch of
lime and lemon extract and a graham
cracker crust man that stuff is hurt
it's real tart and it's cold it's a cold
pie and
real lemony and fruity like icebox pie
they call that or they used to call them
ice yeah in mississippi we call it
icebox pie yeah i think that's but it
didn't it didn't that's a type of pie
like there's because there's types of
pie like sort of like uh some lemon pies
and stuff like that that are ice box
pies yeah you don't bake them right you
bake the crust but then the inside you
just like keep it in the fridge and it
solidifies right before refrigeration we
had things called ice boxes
and then in in the in mississippi and
certain other parts of the south when
the refrigerator came
to fruition they still called those
things ice boxes
as it says well it's a box and there's
ice well there's coldness in it so that
makes sense so there's certain kind of
pies that you don't bake them you you do
you let them chill in the icebox
and uh key lime pie
it's inexpensive and [ __ ] fantastic
especially if you have the coloring
right
um some people have used slight touches
of
green artificial coloring which will
make it make a [ __ ] pie
even though it's just color
for some reason it just tastes better in
your mind the way things look affects
how it tastes yeah well just like yeah
and just a small touch
of artificial coloring to make it
greener
it just makes it [ __ ] pop especially
if the graham cracker crust is just
really well made and if it's kind of
like dark graham crackers
um i've seen some people make it with
like it's a mixture of
graham crackers
dust and
chocolate cracker dust i don't know i
think now you can make key lime pie um
i'm not sure if there's like a stamp
because i've seen it with graham cracker
crust and i've seen it with regular pie
crust yeah you can do both you can do
either way i thought i like it better
with crit with graham cracker
yeah i mean i yeah either either crust
is good i i like regular like
traditional pineapples but graham
cracker crust is good i like it with
graham crackers i will say i really do
like key lime pie i think i slightly
prefer lemon meringue which is kind of
similar
um but not
not quite as tart i guess i like lemon
anything pretty much lemon flavored your
average key lime pie is only about an
inch thick
but sometimes some people have been able
to make them more closer to like an inch
and a half to two inches thick and it's
even better
you know just
depends on what the dish is like what
the pan is like and how much that stuff
you have
and the time it takes to cool it to get
it to congeal but it's just this creamy
lemony pie
very easy to make
uh difficult
difficult to perfect though say you can
execute any recipe online and go yeah
that was pretty good
but what matters is somebody who really
cares about the [ __ ] and starts to fine
tune
that [ __ ] recipe until it's just a
work of art make it fatter make it
greener different kind of crust
different kind of toppings on it the
decorations the presentation all that
[ __ ] matters
you know well yeah you never know what
that one little tweak is that's just
gonna make it sing like gonna put it way
over the top right
but it's cool and tart and um
got a good texture
that is the most florida of pies flora
as [ __ ]
it mixes with alcohol
mixes with alcohol too that's like
that's like something that you could
actually be drunk and eat that and just
[ __ ] love it
this is making me want some pie
i don't think we have any pie out of pie
we ate the last pie
oh yeah we had a berry pie i had a berry
pie it's gone
but that was a while yeah
i have pop tarts
i got two cases of popcorn
that's kind of similar they play forever
if you're drunk if you're drunk enough
you're just like this is kind of like
pie i saw him i saw sam's you know what
i mean because man this [ __ ] are
cheap man they live they last forever it
says you know that's good that's good
emergency rations right there [ __ ]
that's like something they'd give you in
an mre they crumble up
but it wouldn't matter if you gave me
that out in the field in the army
crumbled up [ __ ]
raw pop-tart i'd [ __ ] just
eat it up just with a relish you know
like all that's beautiful
because presentation it doesn't matter
what you're [ __ ] hot
honestly though the strawberry ones are
really the only ones worth of [ __ ]
that's what i got they're strawberries
yeah they're strawberry um
let me tell you people what you do you
get some the cinnamon ones are okay yeah
but they're not strawberry that's yeah
strawberries kind of like strawberry or
blueberry strawberry is kind of like
well no blueberry can i like blueberries
suck a dick i don't like blueberries
this is what you do you get your
strawberry pop tart you get you some
real butter and you melt it in a ramekin
and you get you a paint brush and then
you [ __ ] once the once the butter's
melted you paint both sides of that
strawberry of that pop-tart and put it
in and you put that into the [ __ ]
toaster i mean be careful don't don't
set your taste around come out with
sizzling and it'll have a nice [ __ ]
color and flavor to it to be a lot more
succulent i've done it he said succulent
succulent yeah
that's such a gross word it's not as
gross as moist
i said moist you guys yeah
i don't know pop tarts are weird because
it's kind of like every now and then
like i don't think about them most of
the time
this used to happen
uh when i where i used to work
i'd be like working like weeks and weeks
would go by and i wouldn't think about
it but then every time they'd be like
man
i really want some pop tarts because we
had a um you know we had a snack machine
the other thing and it would usually
have pop tarts in it
so i'd go down there and get pop tarts
look who shows up i know i saw that
tina's showing up and then i toast them
and then i would eat one and i'm like
man that was really good but then i
would eat the other one i'm like ah i'm
gonna be sick now
it's just like it's too much
too much yeah one of them's good but
two of them i i think is too many unless
i'm drunk and then it's just and then
it's fine
uh glenn little said my mom's generation
would put booze in baby bottles yeah i
think so yeah people did that here too
help during teething they told me
oh mom such a joker she's dead i learned
nothing
[Laughter]
i mean they were doing the best they
could
i kind of feel like it was acceptable
not so much in like when we were kids in
the 70s but i kind of feel like the
generation before that like my
grandparents generation
um
[Music]
yeah like you wanted the baby to sleep
he was kind of sick or whatever it's
like man just put some whiskey in there
in the bottle mix it in with the milk
it's fine
it'll help it'll help him sleep tina's
saying if i eat pop tarts and put
[ __ ] peanut [ __ ] chocolate and
drizzle that on there well i like the
strawberry ones and with the strawberry
ones i [ __ ] paint some [ __ ] melted
butter on them and then [ __ ] toast
them that's what i do with them
they're good
but like i said
the reason why they're good is because
uh you can find them on sale sometimes
the [ __ ] sams a big old [ __ ] box
so they're cheap yeah and they keep
forever so that's like
that'll get you through some hard times
in a hurricane
yeah because two pop-tarts is like 350
calories yeah and then that's like a
meal and that's like [ __ ] motivating
you're like oh okay yeah
okay sweet
they're talking about lemon bars yeah
lemon icebox pie and and it's kind of
like kind of like that and and i like
lemonade like anything lemon cake
lemon's good on everything lemon yeah
lemon meringue pie lemon bundt cake oh
yeah bundt cake with lemon icing
i mean i like the thing i like pretty
much any kind of dessert i'm not gonna
turn my nose up at
pretty much anything
but i do have certain preferences
i do like lemon stuff and i like
if you're talking about cake
um
i will take lemon cake or vanilla type
cake over chocolate cake
now i'm not gonna turn my nose up a
chocolate cake either but if you give me
a choice no i would take lemon
yeah i'd probably take lemon more than
anything and you can go down you can go
down to sam's probably costco too and
get two big old [ __ ] things of lemon
juice
for like a couple bucks and from that
you can make gallons of lemonade or all
these little [ __ ] lemon things
and that lemon is cheap you can make a
lot of stuff out of it
i was gonna say too i think that
do you know when i was growing up
every year on my birthday and my mom or
my grandma or whoever was making a cake
for me
um
what kind of cake did i want
do you know what kind of cake i always
wanted every single year for many many
years what is that marble
really why is that one why that one i
don't know that one's not very special
actually well it's i guess it's because
it was mostly vanilla tasting but it had
a little bit of chocolate in it too
because i'm not a big fan like i'll eat
chocolate cake i'm not like i said i'm
not kicking it out of bed or anything
but if you give me a choice between
like i said vanilla or
lemon or even red velvet
i'm gonna choose any of those over
chocolate cake although i will eat
chocolate cake it's good but it's not my
first favorite and i especially don't
like
or i'm not gonna choose like chocolate
cake with chocolate icing on it it's
just it's too much when i was a kid i
like those ridiculous ass pimp ass cakes
like [ __ ] strawberry cake with cherry
frosting and blueberry filling and
[ __ ] anything that was just i liked
anything that was [ __ ] fruity with a
lot of artificial colors in it and
[ __ ] bright see i kind of like that i
didn't like that i don't know why i just
that's what i liked when i was a kid
honestly even if nowadays if i'm going
to have like a cupcake or something like
that i'm always going to want like i
like a vanilla cupcake with vanilla
icing on it or lemon
um or just something like that that's
not chocolate yeah
no and i like red velvet too oh yeah i
really like it right now that's
basically chocolate and tomato tila says
more chocolate cake for me yeah that's
fine and like i said i'll eat chocolate
cake i'm not saying i don't like
chocolate cake because i do but women
love chocolate
but it's well it's not my first choice
though really honestly it's probably at
least as far as cake is concerned yeah
um would you talk about candy
i like chocolate candy but only if it
has
nuts or something crunchy in it you know
what i mean i was never really a huge
fan of chocolate i liked stuff that was
like fruit flavored and honestly if you
gave me a choice between
here's like a plain hershey bar and
here's a zero bar oh i'm taking the zero
bar all day long that's white chocolate
see i'll take the juji fruits yeah see i
don't know to me that seems like a waste
of calories i think skittles or
something those are just a waste of
calories i just like that yeah
well you know yeah everybody's different
i'm just saying i've never really been
into fruity candies i like starburst
yeah um
but again it's not if i'm gonna like
if i'm gonna indulge and i'm gonna eat
some candy like if we're going to the
movies and we're buying like candy
before the movies i'm not gonna get
fruity candy no [ __ ] way yeah cream
cheese i'm gonna get chocolate covered
almonds or
what is the [ __ ] i got last time we went
to the movies we went to 7-eleven
beforehand excited to get gas i was like
well let's get some candy in here
and they had
i didn't really want a candy i said i
just but i want a snack i found these
bags they were 711 brand right
they were cashews
but they were like dill pickle flavor
so they had like dill
flavoring like on the cashews yeah and i
was kind of like oh
this is intriguing
that [ __ ] was delicious speaking of dill
pickle flavor when i was at the [ __ ]
biker bar today
dude at the end of the bar bought me a
[ __ ] shot that was whiskey with a
side of dill pickle juice
hmm
yeah it kind of worked i was like man
that works says yeah it works well yeah
i'm telling you like a lot that's kind
of a big thing yeah whiskey and dill
pickle where you know yeah people are
like mixing drinks with dill pickle
juice which isn't that weird because
i mean think of like a bloody mary right
you can put like pickle juice in there
and i have videos i posted them on my
facebook today if you go on thomas ross
facebook you'll see [ __ ] i posted
damn
it was dead i went down the biker bar
there wasn't many people there but
i didn't have to pay though
[ __ ] everybody bought my drinks
[ __ ] just weird that's how it
happened but i took videos of it and
then tila said yeah they put pickle
juice in dirty martinis yeah they did
i mean [ __ ] i'll drink pickle juice all
day long i love pickles
tila says my wedding cake was chocolate
with raspberry filling not a white cake
an actual chocolate cake and it was a
scandal
i do kind of feel like
yeah and well i don't know i guess in
this day and age people probably
wouldn't care but i do kind of feel like
traditionally the wedding cake was
supposed to be white cake
and if you had a different kind of cake
because remember like i remember this is
going back a long way but i remember
like some people want to do like some
different [ __ ] oh we want cupcakes in
the shape of our donuts or whatever and
their relatives like their old relatives
like complained about it because it
wasn't like a traditional
wedding cake
uh hugo says i like whatchamacallit
those are good actually
do they still make those right
um and tila says if i had to choose i
would get a snickers me too probably and
honestly snickers bars
um
[Music]
man i like to get those and i like to
freeze them
and the fun size snickers are even
better like the ones you get for
halloween the ones that are just like
little bite size
you put those in the freezer
they'll break your teeth but man those
are delicious because you got caramel
you got peanuts you got all that stuff
in there
[ __ ] good
janelle harper said she knew she knew
that biker bar
remember janelle
oh
yeah yeah she's like i know that place
so yeah that's the oasis
midnight at the oh yeah
that just always makes me think of that
song
every time you say it i just think of
that song
zach says the best chocolate i've had
was in germany it was a chocolate bar
that had blueberry flavored liquor
inside it
that'd probably be pretty good now that
i'm not real into blueberry i like
blueberry muffins but that's about the
only application
and i guess blueberry pancakes are okay
but honestly i'd rather have pancakes
without blueberries in them thanks
but
you know i'm like i said i'm not going
to get mad if they're in there
um
let's see remember it guys it's looking
it's uh open lines tonight if you have
anything you want to talk about just go
ahead and drop it down in the comments
well we are talking we're talking about
we're talking about candy bars now we're
just seeing if they want any paranormal
or unsolved mysteries or anything like
that we can dive in at any time
tila says i like butterfingers too yeah
butterfingers butterfingers yeah
those butterfinger blizzards are really
good at dairy queens oh [ __ ] yeah they
are yeah i mean blizzard that's hard to
mess up
ice cream and candy bars you can't
really go wrong all of those are good um
the butterfinger one is good i like the
heath bar one yeah it's good too uh but
and then and the peanut m m one is good
too they do a peanut m m right i haven't
been there a long time i don't really
know
yeah tammy said my mother-in-law ordered
our cake and said it had to be white
so is that still a thing because i do
kind of feel like i mean i don't know
i've been any weddings and
i don't even know how long
but
yeah i feel like for a long time
people's wedding yeah it had to be a
white cake for whatever reason that was
like traditional
but i thought we had kind of gotten over
that stigma because everybody just was
kind of doing their own thing now and
everyone was all right with it but maybe
like some old people are still getting
upset about it well they've got these
little traditions they want you to
adhere to
and see i said oh
like the cake has to be white i never
realized because like i said i don't eat
so even when i because i was married
before but like we just eloped i didn't
even like worry about that but
there's this whole thing where and
especially if you have parents that are
paying for the wedding yeah they want to
be they they want it to be a certain way
even though they're not the ones getting
married so i'm just like [ __ ] butt
out
jesus christ but it's the traditions
that they want to see happen i guess
that's some you know
i i don't know if i had kids
uh you know and they were old enough and
they were getting married or whatever i
even if i was paying for their wedding
i'm not gonna interfere it's not my
[ __ ] wedding yeah it's like you guys
do what you want they took that [ __ ]
real seriously i guess but
i don't know i i kind of feel like
that's that's it's their day
yeah let them have it the way they want
to have it
i don't understand why you're having
like all these people interfering but
that's a thing what i think it's what i
think is funny is that
they're trying to get you to adhere to
these time honored traditions but if you
probably looked at the details they're
not all that time otter they're on no of
course not probably go back to like the
20s the 30s
not that far back really
if that maybe 40s
i don't know i mean most of the most of
the traditions that people have are not
that old they're not that old no so it's
like i don't really know why people are
worrying about it who cares yeah just
like eat what you want like do would you
what do what you want
like i get but i don't understand well i
don't understand like interfering with
other people's [ __ ] like that especially
something as
like a a big deal or significant as a
wedding
i was like i said even if i was if my
kid was getting married and i was like
paying for it i would not dream of
interfering right i was like i'll pay
for it but you do what you want it's
your wedding well here's something
that'll throw why would i butt in here's
here's something that'll throw a monkey
wrench into all that granny thinking
anyway they want a [ __ ] to dress
up in a tuxedo as if that's formal wear
tuxedos were not formal
tuxedos in a day that they appeared were
like totally improper that was something
that a punk rocker would wear i think it
was 20s
only a young crazy [ __ ] would
wear it toward a tuxedo
it was made up out of a bunch of other
things that were around and it was
totally improper
that shirt that short jacket with that
[ __ ] tie when dudes first started to
wear that it was like a zoo suit or
something they're like oh you can't wear
that in here
so tuxedos are not formal wear not
originally
yeah you know like i said it's
everything that
people think of as traditional yeah uh
is not as old as not as long as you
people think it is and not as [ __ ]
formal as you think
i mean look at all the [ __ ] about it's
like oh well you know
for example like oh pink is for girls
uh that's for boys yeah because it was
red
and that was like a masculine color they
flipped it around yeah i mean pink being
for girls that's a fairly recent
uh phenomenon you know what i mean yeah
um
and actually if you look just a hundred
hundred and ten years ago
of pictures of like little baby boys
they had little like white dresses and
[ __ ] on that was just what babies wore
and everything is [ __ ] a
matter of cultural opinion too
like
um
americans
in north america
have kind of culturally
grown up with the ideas that certain
colors match
you go to south america they'll put
colors together that don't from my point
of view don't match but they think they
match
all right they look like [ __ ] i think
sometimes
um but it's cultural
uh here's another example
like when i was [ __ ] signing for this
house and they were talking about the
housing commission and [ __ ]
what it is you can't do this everything
has to be approved what color it's going
to be that says it's funny it's kind of
like they don't [ __ ] trust
your taste in things and she was like no
they don't
and i said where's this coming from
and it turns out
one of the reasons why the hoas are so
uh worried about
you changing the color of your house
is because in haiti
all of the government
buildings
and all of the buildings of important
rich people are painted pink
so when they move here
and then they get a nice house what
color do you think they're going to
paint their house well yeah they're
going to paint a [ __ ] [ __ ] pink
i kind of figured that's where that came
from
we have to have very like subdued colors
we don't want this looking like one of
those countries yeah that's not all
white people well
that's that pink house kind of sucks
though when you think about it it's it's
because i'm not a big fan of pink but it
could be done cool i mean i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna be mad it's a cultural
thing pink doesn't look good on a house
if you ask me
the reason why they want them pink is
because there's a long tradition of
[ __ ]
government buildings and rich people's
houses being paid being pink and that's
just yeah that's their so that's the
color they're gonna go to it's a signal
it's a [ __ ] it's a virtue signal or
it's a it's a wealth signal it doesn't
culturally translate though when you
have when you're living in
you're when you're living in [ __ ]
florida among all these tropical houses
and all these like these old spanish
style because this is actually
spanish-style architecture
if you look at even brand new houses
built here yeah a lot of them are very
mediterranean they're gonna try and make
that [ __ ] look spanish yeah okay
um
so oh yeah
spain didn't have pink
so i understand what they're talking
about
most houses here are kind of like brown
or tan or gray
that's that's kind of well i yeah i kind
of feel like like i said that you know
particularly the last 10 20 years um
you know you've really seen an upsurge
in this kind of like mediterranean which
is like gold browns
uh you know just neutral right colors
right um you buy a half a million dollar
house which we're getting here this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] 475 000. [ __ ]
paints a house pink next to it and all
of a sudden my house loses 50 000 on it
so that's that's that's what they're
trying to prevent
do you know when i was when i was a kid
and i grew up in daytona beach which
i mean obviously like we grew up pretty
poor so i never lived anywhere that had
an hoa
but when i was a kid one of my favorite
houses in daytona beach and it was one
of the rich people houses but it wasn't
in like a planned community or anything
it was actually right on the ocean it
was on a1a it was on the beach side
and whoever owned this house they must
have been millionaires because the house
was [ __ ] massive
but they just said [ __ ] it and they
painted the house all kind of different
crazy colors it's like it's bright blue
it's bright red it had this gun and i
[ __ ] loved it
it was so crazy looking but i was just
kind of like man
look at that [ __ ] they do not give a
single [ __ ] and i am all about it yeah
um but nobody ever complained because i
mean i think their neighbors complained
because they thought it was an eyesore
but tea's going i can't believe i'm
drinking wine why can't you i used to
drink wine all the time
i used to drink wine all the time and
then she goes like there's a gorgeous
black victorian home from berkeley
california very gothic chic oh i've seen
that i've seen that yeah yeah i know the
house of seafood it is beautiful yeah
out actually you would think that a
black house would look [ __ ] up no it
doesn't black houses look really cool
they do you just have to know how to
decorate one it's black and a bunch of
[ __ ] gray black and kind of an off
yeah it's beautiful
if it's done if it's done right it's
[ __ ] really good the problem is you
could never ever unless you were a
millionaire
paint a house gray in florida
the heat the cooling costs would just be
[ __ ] well there's a lot of houses
here that are gray but it's usually like
so it's not it's like lighter gray it's
a lot of great yeah you couldn't paint a
house black here it would just get
[ __ ] hot
yeah you'd roast in there roast it
um i mean i wouldn't mind i wouldn't be
averse to having the outside of the
house black but yeah
it would be like an oven inside we
already have two [ __ ] central units
in this house if it was black you'd
probably need four
and uh [ __ ] i painted this room black
yeah but the whole house yeah yeah i'm
gonna attract all the [ __ ] solar
radiation and just cook it
so you'd need a lot of [ __ ] air
conditioner to keep it cool
but i'm california wouldn't matter
california doesn't get hot
not hot enough to worry about
but um
yeah she used to my wine
i strict white try wine is a good light
uh it's a good light drinking buzz
oriented thing be prepared to [ __ ]
piss it all out that's really what it is
but you gotta drink a lot of it you
gotta continue to drink and it's a wine
is a [ __ ] good drink i used to drink
it by the box sometimes
me my first wife would [ __ ] drink
wine every now and then i kind of wish i
could get more into it you can get into
it the problem of wine is the next
morning it tends to be pretty rough with
the hangover deal
yeah for me it does to be honest not i
mean
i don't get i don't really get that bad
at hangovers anymore
if
i remember to take a bunch of aspirin
before i go to sleep
after i drink a lot if i take a bunch of
aspirin and drinks a whole glass of
water and then go to sleep i usually
wake up
fine yeah i don't usually have a
hangover now i'm usually real tired the
next afternoon
but i don't have like headaches or
nothing back in the 90s you'd go to
walmart and [ __ ] you
you'd be shopping me and my first wife
because there's a box of wine see a
[ __ ] box of merlot there she's like
get four of those things
they were [ __ ] cheap man they were
like
like seven bucks for a [ __ ] big old
box of damn wine like yeah we're gonna
get some of these and we'd be listening
to [ __ ] goth music we'd be listening
to [ __ ] you know like in uh current
93 and all that [ __ ] that's
that sounds fun listen to all that neo
folk music and have the [ __ ] candles
going and [ __ ] [ __ ] david tibet
[ __ ] singing and we'll be just
drinking [ __ ] wine and get loaded
and uh
yeah it was fun it was fun it's not the
same it's not the same as drinking a
hard hard alcohol or beer
actually beer is my least favorite
i don't really like beer that much i
don't either too heavy and you have to
drink a lot of it
beer just makes me sleepy and like i
have to really pee all the time yeah it
makes me feel kind of makes you feel
extremely fat
um wine not so much
wine doesn't make you feel fat i don't
know i don't know why because you still
have to drink a lot of it
but maybe it's lower calorie i don't
know maybe it's less carbs
yeah i don't know what it is
i mean i'll drink beer
bloated on it but yeah
beer honestly because you know sometimes
i'll drink beer if we go to a place that
doesn't have a liquor license like all
they so all they have is beer and wine
so sometimes i'll get beer but
honestly i just have a beer or two and
then i just want to sleep yeah it just
makes me feel like i just ate
thanksgiving dinner
you know it's very very filling and it
just makes me want to pee every five
minutes which that sucks
but you know
uh
tila says box one best at trader joe's
five dollars oh yeah
i have to see the trader joe's around
here i don't think we have those um yeah
we do but um
where are they the closest one
oh we have the other one the sister
version of it aldi's
no that's not the same thing something
okay trader um aldi's european trader
joe's trader joe's there no there's a
trader joe's [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is it
i thought it was over there by that mall
where that world market is
where we used to go that's not that far
from our old house
i thought there was a trader joe's over
there
i don't remember joe's was a european
thing like all of these i don't think
there's two different things i think
yeah but we only have the one there's no
there's the north one in this or nord
ensued or whatever
um we only have like it's two different
companies but we only have like the one
that's and then trader joe's is kind of
like an american version of all these
and doesn't trader joe's have two
different forms
i don't i think i don't know actually i
think trader joe's is the same trader
joe's is kind of well it's a similar
thing in that they have their own house
brands that a lot of people like better
yeah they're better than the fam then
yeah yeah the name brands
i don't think i've ever been to no
trader joe's yeah
you know it's supposed to have real good
stuff like real good hot sauces and real
good yeah yeah
i've heard that too we do it there is
one around here i just don't you you
should you should google that yeah and
then i'll look for it and they have a
like i thought i think they have their
own soft drinks their own drinks they're
supposed to be really good yeah they
have their own house brands yeah like
like i said like aldi does kind of in a
lot of ways
and a lot of people like those better
than uh yeah regular branding well the
dude that owns it knew he was doing we
saw we saw a whole [ __ ] yeah i think
company man yeah there's a channel
called company man on youtube y'all need
to check it out it's a good channel real
good yeah he puts up he puts one or two
videos up a week actually company man
and he will tell you the nature of every
one of these companies who owns them and
what their marketing strategy is and how
strong or weak they are and he did one
on trader joe's
and i was like oh man we got i want to
go to that
but i've never been to one i think
there is one
do you remember i can't remember what
that shopping plaza was called but
remember like that whole shopping area
where the old toys r us was
yeah yeah
i think there's one around there like
where the world market is
where the old spirit halloween was right
like a couple years ago
i think there's one in there okay but i
might be
crazy or it might be like around there
somewhere yeah he said you want to go we
do have one somewhere you want to go
down there and like buy their sausages
and yeah and their [ __ ] soft drinks
and their mixes on things and
like uh they'll have energy drinks that
are just just for trader joe's there's
and they're they're supposed to be
fantastic
well that's how they can keep low
overheads it's the same thing with aldi
and the company company man did a video
on aldi as well everything from aldi's
is good um yeah and that's kind of how
they keep costs down is that i mean the
aldi here does sell some big name brand
[ __ ]
but their whole thing is
they keep low overheads because they
have their own branded stuff
yeah and their branded stuff that they
make is
you know equal to
you know or better than yeah some of the
brand name [ __ ]
so you know what i mean
um you know see this is it's not not
that expensive yeah here that aldi's and
that kind of stuff is cheap yeah here
it's very inexpensive yeah we used to
get it all day all the time actually
yeah because there was an aldi not that
far from our old house and i think
there's
i don't know if we're still like is that
the closest one now that we've moved i
haven't checked
she said the trader joe has a great
customer service and a nice liquor
selection that sounds good
yeah
there's one around here somewhere yeah
we'll just have to go to aldi's here
the quality is extremely good it's
european
stuff repackaged or sometimes a super
but i think it's repackaged as their own
stuff and it's like
cheaper than walmart
or walmart prices but the quality is a
lot better
yeah i mean [ __ ] we've got from there
that was just kind of like you know aldi
brand or like some weird off-brand or
whatever um a lot of that shit's like
really really good
to be honest with you
best supermarket in florida's publix
publix is the best they got their own
brand stuff it's good and their own
brand stuff is [ __ ] top notch it's
really good their their publix brand ice
cream is
up there with bluebell ice cream and i
love bluebell that's quite a compliment
their ice cream is [ __ ] fantastic
and and anything from their deli is
super good
if you want and their bakery is also
excellent if you want a big old sub
sandwich or a big [ __ ] grinder or
whatever it is i don't know what country
in in in up up north they call it a
grinder if you want a big old sub
sandwich they got cuban sandwiches stuff
you go to [ __ ] publix and for six or
seven bucks you get one that [ __ ] big
cut in half
beautiful whatever you want and they'll
make it for you right make it right
there in front of you whatever you want
there'll be a big line of people then i
have big old buckets of fried chicken
or barbecued chicken or big rotisserie
chickens like four or five different
flavors you can get a big rotisserie
chicken
for like four bucks
i mean it's cheaper than a raw chicken a
lot cheaper
because it's the chicken it's the
chickens that are getting ready to reach
the expiration date they have so they
cook them yeah so you just cook them and
they sell them for like four bucks well
and they do like deals too where it's
like you can buy a big bag of rotisserie
chicken and
you get a couple sides you can pick
whatever sides and then the [ __ ]
hawaiian egg salad potato salad and some
rolls yeah and it's what like 10 bucks
12 i think it's 12 bucks 12 bucks or
12.99 yeah and it's better than what you
would get and it'll feed like four
people yeah yeah a lot better than kfc
and um but it's not a bag of chicken
it's a big box and it'll be [ __ ]
rotisserie chicken or barbecued chicken
or fried chicken or whatever and that's
publix publix is the [ __ ]
i mean to be honest with you when you
were not here for two weeks because you
were visiting your dad
um i think i went to publix pretty much
every day yeah and just bought [ __ ] from
their dollars yeah you can watch it you
can go to the poker because they have
like salads they have like pre-made cold
sandwiches
they have cold fried chicken tenders
they have all kind of fun chips soups go
to the publix deli and for four bucks
you get two big ol slices of quiche
lorraine yeah
that pre-made quiche
anything they got everything they got
all kinds of stuff all the sides baked
beans
[ __ ]
potato salad
see people piss and moan about nowadays
but grocery stores back when we were
kids
they didn't have all that [ __ ] no they
do now
even when dixie has upped its game yep
to try to be about as good as public
yeah because when i was a kid we always
went to win dixie because that's what
was closest right
but when i was little
winn-dixie or goodings i don't even
think goodings is right ugly wiggly or
piggly wiggly yeah that was kind of like
the cheaper story wiggly you didn't go
to publix when i was a kid because that
was too rich for my blood that was like
in the rich part of town so we never
went to publix
um
even though nowadays they're pretty
comparable publix and windexy pretty
much the same
but
yeah back in the old days when dixie was
kind of seen as like kind of a little
bit of the ghetto yes kind of grocery
store was the public was kind of like
the ritzy grocery store yeah and and
piggly wiggly was [ __ ] redneck as
[ __ ] that was [ __ ] i feel like
goodings was too that was trailer park
roses
remember i don't think we had roses
roses was just when i was a kid we
always went to goodings and i don't even
think they have goodings anymore
the goodings was right next to the
archer the arthur treachers
which back then was a sit-down
restaurant yeah you can walk into do
they still have arthur treasures i don't
know you could walk into a [ __ ] you
could you could walk into a winn-dixie
now and go through the salad bar or the
sidebar
they got [ __ ]
ziti
meatballs with
tomato sauce on them
just
all
kinds of [ __ ] and for five bucks come
out of there with [ __ ] a huge pile of
damn food for five or six you couldn't
even eat all that
and um it would be better
than the kind of fast food or kind of
food you would get
say like in boston like at a boston
[ __ ] italian
sidewalk [ __ ] italian restaurant
where they got you know
meatballs and spaghetti and maybe some
pizza yeah it'd be better than that for
like half the price
and i'm comparing the prices from 10 20
years ago 20 years ago still cheaper
so now man the food game has been
accelerated at a nationwide level well
they had to they had to
you can get all kinds of food everywhere
for pretty damn cheap
and nobody's
well the thing about it is that people
are a lot more discerning nowadays they
know bad food they know what people know
what bad food tastes like back in the
70s people just like took what they were
getting like
they didn't know any better 80s too i
got gram granters i got granters in the
[ __ ] comment section we were coming
up in michigan in the 80s when we were
in high school
and we'll tell you that there were
little mom [ __ ] italian restaurants
that
it was just 80s stodge for [ __ ] seven
bucks they'd give you a whole bunch of
damn pasta with cheap sauce and a
[ __ ] some shitty ass [ __ ]
meatballs in it or something
it's they couldn't get away with that
anymore
they you people would go like nah yeah
you'd go out of business right they all
tasted the same they all tasted the same
it's just not like it was
with those damn [ __ ] menus that was
the
we had to take put the plastic letters
in it remember those
little plastic letters yeah now it's a
[ __ ] screen and it's moving with
[ __ ]
it's the future yeah it's the future
yeah it's even more in the future than
[ __ ] back to the future
david june says food lion was the rich
person store now this is very
interesting because
now this is fairly recent because this
is when i still lived in daytona
i moved out of daytona in what 2010
2011.
uh but up until i moved away
the grocery stores that were like a mile
from my house because i would walk down
there to do my grocery shopping we had a
winn-dixie on this side and a food lion
on this side
um
the food lion was considerably more
ghetto then the winn-dixie was pretty
good yeah gotta say
food lion was like worse every now and
then if they were out of something in
the winn-dixie i would go to the food
lion but
they were both like right next to each
other and like pretty ghetto yeah but so
that's like really funny but like i said
when dixie is not ghetto everywhere it
just depended on what
neighborhood it was in
tito is going i think publix might be on
par with [ __ ] safeway or
uh
and and droquinos i don't know what
andrew king is i remember safeway as a
kid
safeway when i was a kid was kind of
like
crappy in a certain way it was okay but
it wasn't that great safeway would be
about like
win dixie it's better publix is better
than you can google publix and look at
it it would have been better than the
safeway at least safeway from the 70s in
california when i lived there and in the
80s
um
safeway was about like on par of
winn-dixie all right and then you all
want to laugh at piggly wiggly
yeah piggly wiggy was suss back in the
days but piglet wiggly was kind of like
um
it was a southern supermarket chain
it was kind of like in areas where
the population was a lot smaller so it
was kind of like
a dollar general store it was like
imagine a dollar general store was a
full-size supermarket that's what that's
what piggly wiggly was
um it wasn't anything unusual about it
it was just lower end
yeah prices i mean piggly wiggly yeah to
me
i think i was only in a piggly wiggly a
couple times in my whole entire life
but we used to shop at the goodings yeah
that wasn't that far from my
grandmother's house when i was really
little mary says i love cuban sandwiches
and that's kind of like yeah publix
cuban sandwich is good yeah mary it is i
mean i lived in tampa for a while and
that's kind of like
other than
actual cuba tampa that's where you want
to go to get like some good ass cuban
sandwiches
tea is going i've heard a publix chicken
was the bomb other youtubers talk about
publix chicken yes
public chicken is
the quality level is
above kfc
yeah oh big time oh yeah a lot and their
subs are way better right than pretty
much any sub chain yeah now i guess
obviously like way better than subway
because subway is not that great the
thing is about publix is that it also
depends on which publix you go to
some people working in publix are
putting too much goddamn salt in the
damn batter so sometimes you'll get it's
like it's like extra crispy
from say like
you know [ __ ] popeyes or something
but sometimes it can be a little too
salty but you can always return that
[ __ ] chances are you're at home already
so you're not gonna return it
um
now
when kfc is hidden with the original
blend it's good it is good my dad worked
at kfc for a very long time when kfc's
good it's good i like their original
but publix is very reliable and it's
[ __ ] real good man real good [ __ ]
got a super chat you okay half naked you
yeah thank you very much yeah hey my
husband did time
in
three one eight seven from third and 187
from 99 to first and the first in the
five years well there you go tom thank
you very much
uh yeah the 187 rockets ons uh they were
out of fort campbell kentucky
toughest
actually i'm gonna say i was in three
two seven i was in first in three two
seven recon platoon
also known as tiger force
back when we were in vietnam and they
were the most i was from the most
decorated platoon
uh in the us army
but i must say that
the 187th
regiment was the toughest airborne
infantry regiment in the united states
army
even better than the fibo deuce
now the 506th
i was in the 506 when it was attached to
second id
in korea up on the dmz because we were
on loan back then
and 506
they were [ __ ] tough too they're like
up there with the 187
506 187
uh the 327 were wild asses those are
[ __ ] drinkers gamblers high-risk
[ __ ] it's always been that way
5-0 deuce were always kind of like the
smart guys they were kind of like in the
middle um
uh but yeah yeah 187 good unit good unit
but 506 yeah we bros we're bros
i'm going to show you guys a picture
piggly wiggly
we'll try to find you a classic photo of
piggly wiggly
all right
the [ __ ] piggly wiggly sign was a pig
a cartoon pig face smiling at you and he
had a damn little [ __ ] cap on like he
was the butcher
which that's a little weird yeah i am a
pig and i'm going to be killing my
brethren and i'm certain
i'm a pig servant
yeah
that's messed up
there he is
how'd you find the piggly boot yeah
see that's did anybody think about the
repercussions of that piglet wiggly i'm
serving swine pig serving swine he's a
cannibal is what he's saying no i'm
feeding you my own people
yeah essentially they weren't thinking
like nobody thought about that
okay nobody was like
that's hilarious that's a new piggly
wiggly
they didn't look like that when i was a
kid okay is piggly wiggly still around
yeah they're around
i mean i thought they were yeah they're
around
didn't some somebody sent us a piggly
wiggly like a
a shopping bag you know what i mean like
a sustainable shop yeah i'm gonna try to
find i still have that a classic
what a piggly wig that looked like back
in the 1970s
i don't you know
that's the thing were you talking about
fried chicken yeah
yeah i'm gonna say look i love kfc much
of the next oh although i'm i'm a more
crispy girl than original i'll eat red
original i'm not gonna like i said i'm
not gonna [ __ ] on that that's good too
but i like the crispy [ __ ]
yeah however i am gonna say
publix chicken from their deli is better
than kfc that's classic pig not as
greasy this is okay so that doesn't have
the pig on it no
well blow it up don't just show it to me
they can't see it
that's that's the piggly wiggly i grew
up with
that's some classic [ __ ] like something
you'd find on a strip mall [ __ ] that
looks like the tgny yeah yeah next to my
grandma's house yeah i grew up yeah do
you guys remember tgny
do you remember tj yeah
i remember ggy what the [ __ ] was it what
did they sell in there like everything
it was it was kind of like a little
dollar general yeah it was kind of like
yeah it was like a dollar general or
like a um your [ __ ] um
they just kind of had everything well it
was everything well before they had
walmart or target like superstores
um that was where you went it was like a
general store like a general store yeah
yeah it was like that
but that was um i remember like when i
was really little my grandma's house
across the street and down a block
was a little strip mall
that had a tgny
and a hair salon
and a bowling alley
and
something else
was it was a save a lot but it wasn't a
save a lot back then it was
whatever
whatever was like the pre
like the 70s equivalent of a save a lot
t says that piggly wiggly would be a
cool t-shirt
there's some the older version of it
which is a disc that says piggly wiggly
with his face in it that is kind of cool
just if you wear that [ __ ] people were
like what the [ __ ] is that
mike bird says piggly wiggly had to use
a cartoon pig because not many customers
knew how to read
it
probably true
uh hugo says jenny kfc or popeyes
ooh
in the pants
it yeah it depends what you're getting
it depends on the place which one
honestly i ate a lot i probably ate way
more kfc than any normal person because
both my parents worked there my uncle
when i was growing up for many many
years owned a kfc franchise he owned
pretty much all the kfc's
in the central florida area at least in
the daytona beach area and i think some
he owned some other ones too like um
up into uh
did he go as far as saint augustine i
can't remember now but he owned like a
lot of kfc's like in this area
so anytime what i'm getting florida's
[ __ ] uh-oh
so anytime we were having a family
gathering
everybody would bring big buckets of kfc
because you know
he owned the [ __ ] so he got it for free
and my dad worked there for a long time
my mom worked there for a long time so
we ate kfc all the [ __ ] time i'm
gonna tell you this
i do like kfc but popeyes is good too
it's gonna depend on who is staffing
these restaurants well that's that's
also a factor you want to know the
restaurant if you go in there and it
looks [ __ ] dirty and you smell little
[ __ ] chicken grease and those tables
haven't been cleaned in a while and the
[ __ ] floor is all [ __ ] sticky and
those [ __ ] people working in there
don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i'm talking about
they go on there and they're [ __ ]
acting asses and [ __ ] don't eat in
either one of them you want to go to a
[ __ ] good restaurant where the people
but there's good management to keep them
[ __ ] in line
because this there's the problem
is sanitation
that's with all those chicken places
chicken is a dirty animal to cook but to
begin with and when you're deep frying
and you're deep frying a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] oil gets everywhere i've worked
in kitchens this is my [ __ ] job and
if they can't stay on top of that
[ __ ] oil cross contamination you can
get sick eating out of those places if
you look through history and talk about
[ __ ] that have gotten sick it's
coming from chicken places
chicken is [ __ ] difficult to cook in
mass and to keep the sanitation good
well especially fried chicken because
it's hard to determine is it done is it
done once and then you got [ __ ] oil
everywhere and if you don't clean that
oil up the new oil mixes with the oil
oil it gets on the [ __ ] chicken you
got [ __ ] nasty [ __ ] mixing
because it's hard to clean up after all
that
so you go in there and you make sure
that this place is being cleaned
regularly before you do any [ __ ]
business in there and i'll tell you what
kfc's got a [ __ ] notorious reputation
for having some shitty
locations but a good location can be
hidden you just got to make sure
is that place being run right is
management keeping those employees
[ __ ] in line
if both are working fine
it's up to you they're about the same
bum will give popeyes the nod when it
comes to [ __ ]
red beans and rice
popeyes red beans and rice is the best
bed bread beans and rice you can get and
everybody in the south will tell you
that yeah pretty much when you're
[ __ ] trying to make it it's like
mcdonald's in their french fries the
motherfucker's got bad ass french fries
if you're trying to make red beans and
rice you're trying to copy what popeye's
has there's good
very good
if you go to a popeyes you probably
should just get the red beans and rice
that's [ __ ] back in the day i used to
like their shrimp po boys but i don't
think they make them anymore right
now we went to popeyes probably a couple
months ago and they didn't have
when it comes to if you if you've got a
good
kfc next to you really what you want to
focus on is the [ __ ] original recipe
chicken
and the
motherf
[ __ ]
mashed potatoes and gravy
and that coleslaw
hard to beat that
hard to beat that mashed potatoes and
gravy it's not
there's something about the flavor of
that gravy
it is only available at kfc
and that gravy flavor profile is badass
my dad knows how to make it yeah he
worked there a long time and that was
the thing if you go back into history
and see what the colonel was mad at he
was always mad about the gravy
what is the colonel that great the
colonel would back when the colonel was
alive
he would go and goes is that gravy
consistent
because that was his recipe that he
clinged on to and it had to be that
particular flavor of gravy
so kfc it's gravy
that's what you're looking for
popeyes red beans and rice
the chicken
is kind of wet and what i mean it's
pretty good yeah either one
yeah i can take either one either one
but i mean if you're gonna have a fast
food place you really have to have at
least one thing like mcdonald's has
their french fries
you know other place have other like
wendy's has their frosty you have to
have one thing that stands out that
stands out that nobody else has right
so to give people a reason to come there
specifically tila says tom and jenny do
you all like chicken and waffles [ __ ]
yes oh yeah [ __ ] we get that soul food
restaurant [ __ ] chantelle get there
from chantals it's a couple doors down
from mannequins in downtown sanford i'm
sure we brought this up before there's a
place called chantals yeah uh that's a
couple doors down for mannequins in
downtown sanford yeah uh if you go there
in the middle of the night they're open
till 4 a.m
but after
11 or after midnight it's a very limited
menu
um but you can get chicken and waffles
and it's delicious yeah now it's it's
more than i can eat
it's a lot
but it's really really good but if you
go there in the daytime i would uh get
their shrimp and grits their shrimp and
gritses
divine
i got a video
and jenny
oh yeah i forgot about that at chantals
that this is a while back well that's
like several months ago
where did should you go i don't know
here it is
no it's not
let's talk about arby's curly fries wait
arby's has curly fries
i haven't been to arby's have i been to
arby's ever
i don't think i've been here's jenny and
her giant boobs oh that was when i was
bright at frankenstein yeah at
chantals at chantal's this was i eating
chicken and waffles no i was waiting for
waiting for them and i'm sitting there
that's back when i was deep in the test
and the testosterone lust and i was just
trying yeah look at that look at that my
[ __ ] was [ __ ] rocked up my [ __ ]
mouth was [ __ ] water and i was like
and i'm going into the food and she
started my chicken and she's mad
she's mad she's mad at me she's going
get that [ __ ] camera off me
i'm gonna hit this
[Laughter]
it's like two o'clock in the morning and
i'm looking at her leg and [ __ ] [ __ ]
it
i am in court
i am in court i was just hungry i forgot
about this i was i was drunk and hungry
drunkery i was drunk
tila says all i see are boobs yeah
they are giant boobs
i mean you know this is why this is why
my shoulders hurt all the time
i'm trying to get her up in that [ __ ]
gym you [ __ ] me get some more muscle
on there so she could support all that
[ __ ]
that's not how that's not how that works
that's how exactly how it works yeah
okay
okay
mary connolly says taco bell used to
sell a salad in a bowl and it was like 3
000 calories yeah
honestly a lot of fast food places
i feel like they were kind of like
they were making it like look we're
being healthy we are we're offering
salads
but the salads that they offer in a lot
of like mcdonald's for example some of
the salads that they serve have more
calories than their burgers do yeah
because of all the stuff they put on
them
and that's going back to what i was
saying earlier about grits
it's not so much that grits have a lot
of calories it's all the [ __ ] that you
put in there
salad
has almost no calories until you start
putting on you start putting bacon bits
and ranch dressing and [ __ ] [ __ ] and
sturdy you start putting all this [ __ ]
on there it's not really a salad anymore
at that point because it's just kind of
like you might as well just eat a
[ __ ] quarter pounder at that stage
because
you're putting so much like [ __ ] on
there
um
yeah you've never been to arby's for i
don't think i have i been to rb i'm sure
i've been to an arby's at some point in
my life
i've lived almost a half century yeah
i've been to harvey's many times it's
okay but i feel like i haven't been
there since i was a kid probably the
problem with arby's is that you just
don't get very much for your money
because they're giving you
they're giving you [ __ ] like roast beef
slices and
sliced [ __ ] pork slices and [ __ ]
and you can't get a whole lot for your
money but i do like
our bees i especially like the damn
horsey sauce and the arby's sauce i put
on there
but uh
i'd be curious to go and see what and
see what their game is like nowadays the
value wasn't there the last time it went
out yeah but that was probably like a
long time 20 years ago yeah as i said
most restaurants at least ones that are
still around i kind of feel like they've
really had to up their game
recently well the thing with arby's is
it's about sliced meat
and it's hard to do sliced meat cheap
cheap enough to compete with say like
you know what i mean mcdonald's
so it was always a little bit more
expensive although mcdonald's isn't as
cheap as it used to be either
you know i mean we get two meals and
it's like almost 20 bucks yeah to be
honest which isn't that cheap
um well mary connolly says we have
crystals yeah we have that too
uh used to be 15 cents yeah how much are
crystals burgers now it's kind of like
white castle it
it is white castle
i think it's the same we've had crystal
since i was a kid i was to get that when
i was little all the time
white castle was they used to be 10
cents per burger white castle is the
original hamburger that's that's what it
was uh it elevated over time
to become this big round thing you know
what i mean originally it was nothing
more than a meat cracker on a damn
[ __ ]
dinner roll yeah pickles yeah it wasn't
much to a hamburger people didn't want
to eat them when they first showed up it
was considered to be foreign food in the
early 1900s which is hilarious when you
think yeah they put them right outside
[ __ ] factories because it was a
factory based [ __ ] economy back then
they had to hire doctors to stand out
there and tell everybody that it was
okay
to go in there and eat those things
they're totally healthy it's fine
but here's the thing we laugh at that
now
they were probably far better than what
the average person ate back then well
yeah diets back then were terrible yeah
um mostly they eat canned food
uh
this whole thing about
hey you know [ __ ] back in the good
old days no not in the early 1900s early
1900s was [ __ ]
yeah they were eating terrible [ __ ]
food back then especially we're spoiled
nowadays it was pre-refrigeration
everything was canned the quality was
bad the [ __ ] uh just the way they
sealed up cans they had rotten meat in
the damn meat can
so um but
white castle and the hamburger
which was considered to be more like
something german than it was american at
the time it was considered to be
foreign and exotic when it appeared it
did deliver on its claims that it was
healthy fast food that a worker could
eat quickly and you'd get all your
nutrition that you would need for the
day compared to what they were eating
yeah yeah probably probably better than
what they were eating sure so they
weren't lying it's just uh it was just
another time
uh and it was all relative it's all
relative sure
it was a damn meat cracker with holes in
it to make it cook faster yeah it would
go quicker onions oil
from the [ __ ] cooking meat
um you they got
a real light fluffy
bread which is a dinner roll
with the best with pickle on it
and the best preserves preserved
vegetables that you could get back in
the early 1900's which was heinz
okay
which was ketchup
and mustard
and i think that was it i don't even
think they had mayonnaise
at that time it was just ketchup and
mustard and pickle
that was it with onion
and those were vegetables back in those
days
pickles
mustard and ketchup what i remember
back in those days when i was a kid in
the 70s yeah we used to get bags of
crystals all the time yeah
they did not have ketchup on them it was
mustard and onions
and that was it no pickle and a pickle
pickle yeah
i put ketchup on it you put it at home
right
but um because we had ketchup at home
they didn't put ketchup on i think fro i
think farmer mustard onions pickle that
was all that was on it i think if i
remember correctly when you got your um
white castle back in the day they had
the dispenser to squish the uh oh well
see my grandpa would always go pick them
up okay yeah you did the squish and
bring them home in a big bag they would
squish the [ __ ] vegetables sauce on
it which was tomato or that that's they
call that [ __ ] vegetable sauce okay
you're doing with the early 1800s that
went up until the 80s so yeah vegetable
sauce ketchup is a vegetable which is
ketchup and [ __ ] one tomatoes of
fruit
uh two ketchup's not a vegetable so
right by any stretch they didn't know uh
they were just trying to give you a full
meal
and there was only one other competitor
i'm going to go ahead and give my [ __ ]
my [ __ ] wops out there some [ __ ]
credit because i love my italians
there was only one other meal that was
close to that and that was a slice of
pizza but that was only chicago and new
york
more more or less isn't it hilarious
that at one point everybody considered
pizza foreign yeah
well i remember cookbooks from when i
was a kid that were my grandmother's
cookbooks where spaghetti meatballs was
a foreign food
um
during the time of alphonse capone there
were whole
alphabets alphonse capone
there were whole
newspaper articles written about the
magic of pizza
explaining to explain to people what
pizza was look at this newfangled thing
right and why gangsters liked it so much
it gave them the energy again i remember
reading the ad [ __ ] they would say
[ __ ] like that
gives gangsters energy love to like pop
some [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
i love it i love it something else
roaring 20s no matter what they [ __ ]
tell you if you read in the newspaper
they love the gangsters
that was that what they were celebrating
papers and they were bringing alcohol to
people sure they didn't [ __ ] believe
it nobody believed in [ __ ]
uh uh prohibition prohibition yeah that
was a mistake the [ __ ] yeah how'd
that work out so good no no the [ __ ]
rum runners and the gangsters of old
were who were local folk here they were
the ones that made all the [ __ ] they
made all the party happy and the sheriff
so yeah i know they love those dudes
everybody loves the dude that makes the
party happy they had to explain to the
american public at large what pizza was
and that's really what made it famous
and if you go back into those old
because i've studied the history of food
if you go back
into those old newspaper articles
there's already a war between chicago
and new york pizza yeah this is going
back a long way there's already war
they're like i will take either one
they're both good yeah they're both good
but they're like no no no no no no
real pizza is chicago pizza and then you
got these guys in there no no no no no
real pizzas new york pizza and there was
a dinner [ __ ] needs to be able to
[ __ ] foldable yeah that's what new
yorkers say chicago pizza is more like a
[ __ ] pizza pie it's deep dish yeah
it's more like a casserole yeah and some
of it but it's still good some of it had
a second crust over the top of it a
pizza pie yeah and it was a meal in a
slice
and it was everything you needed all
your meat your cheeses and your
vegetables and your bread all in the
same all in one slice a fab [ __ ]
like me and alphonse we're going to sit
there and eat a whole thing
everybody does it the shit's addictive
now [ __ ] new york slice was something
that you could fold yeah it was big but
it was like floppy you could fold it up
and like
and you could buy a whole pizza
and then eat part of it and then take
the pizza in the box because they served
it in boxes and you could put that on
top of your radiator
and while you went back to work at your
office it could stay there and stay warm
until the work day was over
and you could eat again at a a dinner so
you had lunch and dinner and a pizza
yeah good deal so it was that was the
italian advantage of pizza is it was two
meals
when you bought a pizza it was lunch and
dinner
you could take it home and share it
so which they did
they didn't eat that much look at it
they were low protein [ __ ] they
were they were kind of little
or fat depending on how rude they were
in general muscular
back then they just
the diet wasn't there
and the idea of [ __ ]
slinging iron wasn't there yet they
tried to teach him
you know
[ __ ]
oh was his name
eugene sandow
and some and pandora and all those guys
but that was a [ __ ]
that was a [ __ ] science you know what
i mean it was like you know that was
like some secret science on
diet and exercise you take so much [ __ ]
for granted people you take so much [ __ ]
for granted well like we were saying
before a lot of tradition traditions are
not that old yeah they're not that old
less than a hundred less than a century
and you don't realize how good your how
good your diets are
compared oh i don't take anything for
granted just
70 years honestly just growing up in the
70s the shitty food that we ate back
then and put up with
that no one would have put up with
nowadays no i remember right
well a lot of the [ __ ] a lot of the
uh the a lot of the [ __ ] mojo from
new york and california was really
old-school ways based on how good the
food was well that's everywhere now
everywhere now see that's cool so it's
just been democratized and i mean
honestly when i was growing up as a kid
it's just kind of like like i said even
italian food when i was very little was
still kind of considered foreign chinese
food was considered foreign um
so it was like kind of a rare thing and
it's like even if you had it it was like
some americanized weird at like you know
the [ __ ] lachoy [ __ ] you'd buy at the
grocery store terrible which is terrible
right um so the fact that you can even
in smaller towns get anything you can go
out and get pretty much anything you
want i mean unless you live in the
middle of the middle of nowhere
i mean [ __ ] man even we live kind of in
the country
mile up the road there's a really really
good japanese restaurant right they got
[ __ ] stuff they're really good they
got it's really good they got
temperatures they got people working in
it yeah they got like really so and or
maybe it might be chinese it's hard to
tell that would not have happened no not
back in the 70s no
um and then so i go through the work the
the most deprived inter
state is the one one of the ones that i
partially grew up which is mississippi
there it has great southern food it was
not known for foreign food
last time when i was there you guys
walked you guys were with me when i went
there
to go for my dad's [ __ ] heart surgery
i went through hattiesburg mississippi
and they had a
[ __ ] um
a chinese restaurant there
with uh an eastern staff and i asked for
general general so's chicken and it was
the best general sized chickens i had
in mississippi is in mississippi
yeah yeah and and and it here's the deal
it wasn't
instead of
a hosting sauce they used a little bit
of barbecue sauce because they couldn't
get hosting sauce and it was [ __ ]
fantastic
and i've made that for her sometimes
yeah instead of seeing just put a little
argue in it this whole scene is similar
to barbecue
and you know the whole idea behind
chinese american food is to deliver a
[ __ ] great product for [ __ ] cheap
none of that's exotic nothing it's it's
not made out of anything exotic it's
presentation and and and and
it's yeah it's the mixture of in the
mixture yeah and [ __ ] i already did
that [ __ ] i was going like man this is
[ __ ] good it was better than the [ __ ]
i get in boston or new york and i'm
going what did they do differently and i
went i'm eating and eating it's the same
price
i'm going this is different man this is
[ __ ] great and i'm going
what is this oh
that's not hosting that's [ __ ]
barbecue sauce
it worked it worked yeah yeah
but see that's the thing i like that's
honestly i think that's one of the best
things that the internet has brought
yeah is everything is just kind of like
now wherever you are it's about to say
um
you can find out whatever's like if you
want to cook some like exotic [ __ ]
back in the 70s you couldn't do that
couldn't even order it nope if you did
order it it would take forever to get
there
honestly if you would want to if you
were eating sushi in the 70s i kind of
like
you were exotic like everybody thought
you were a weirdo yeah like not maybe
not in new york city or whatever but
like in [ __ ] florida for sure
i remember when i was a kid i'm drinking
tequila right now when i was a kid out
in california in the 70s
people when people drinking drinking
tequila that was some exotic [ __ ] mexico
was only a [ __ ] hour away
two hours away do you know that i just
remembered that was exotic [ __ ]
i just remembered
there was a whole
thing
in the movie the breakfast club yeah the
john hughes movie which came out in what
84 yeah
um and one of the things one of the
signifiers that made molly ringwald's
character
rich was that she was eating she had she
brought sushi for lunch
and she had the whole thing and like the
dude like the the criminal dude didn't
like know what the sushi what the [ __ ]
is that like that
which is funny because now everybody
[ __ ] eats everybody has that it's not
exotic but back in the 80s yep
yeah you saw that and you were just like
yeah what the [ __ ] is that weird [ __ ]
and raw fish gross and i've been all
over [ __ ] boston new york [ __ ]
california [ __ ] brazil [ __ ] europe
and that little sushi restaurant right
up the street is as good as any other
ones
man they got good ass food up there and
we've been there a couple times yeah
it's like and that's a really good
japanese and that chef is doing his own
thing that's his own menu and it's his
own creations and
you can only get that there but it's
[ __ ] good
well that kind of foodism and the
ability to get that kind of [ __ ] wasn't
around when we were in the 70s or 80s
no
so the world has gotten a lot better
and here's the thing that i try to tell
people we don't need these [ __ ]
that has nothing to do with government
or anything it's just normal technology
it's because we have the internet with
really good telecommunications and
everybody knows what everybody else is
everybody knows what everybody else is
doing sure and you can get all these
[ __ ] supplies
so you don't need this top down [ __ ]
you really don't need everybody is
taking care of themselves
people solve their own [ __ ] problems
how you gonna make a sushi out in the
middle of nowhere oh well no i got
here's the recipe oh we can get all
these components they'll be here
tomorrow
that's all you need that's all you need
anybody can make anything anywhere all
places are about the same now
you can be in it
i order [ __ ] and buy [ __ ] here in
florida or even out in mississippi
[ __ ] even back in the late 90s
stuff that it would be back in the day
you could only get if you were in l.a
yeah like you could only get those shoes
if you were in l.a well not anymore you
can get those shoes anywhere
it's a it's a wonder and you guys are
taking it for granted you [ __ ]
you shouldn't people are but honestly
like people we're gen x so we were like
right on the cusp we were on the cusp so
we lived half our lives without it right
and then half our lives with it yeah it
made a big difference it did well at
least we appreciate it because i'm like
yeah would i want to go back to a time
there were some things that were kind of
cool about that but
everything was harder the supply chain
everything was harder the supply chain
[ __ ] is so much better now than it
was i mean it's so much easier nowadays
holy crap you can find anything back
then it was kind of a pain you could
find any song you want we didn't realize
it was a pain because it seemed normal
we didn't know any better yeah but
looking back on them like god everything
was like a big giant pain let's check
the uh let's check this tila says for
fast food i usually do habit burger or
five guys i actually really really like
five guys um it's it's a tad pricey but
i mean all their shit's pretty tight and
they make the [ __ ] like right there yeah
and they'll give you like a whole
[ __ ] bag full of fries man yeah
you know i i ordered
pro tip i always just order a small fry
because it's cheaper because they're
gonna give you like a whole [ __ ] bag
full of fries they give you about the
same amount anyway so it's like why
bother paying for a large fry they're
gonna give you a whole bag full of
french fries anyways
um yeah so uh i love the mcdonald's
barbecue rib sandwich oh is that the
mcrib
i was never a fan of that i know it's
like a big thing and a lot of people are
really into it because it's limited
edition so you kind of feel like ooh
it's like special i don't like it though
tina goes general sews with barbecue
sauce yeah sounds amazing it was it was
[ __ ] amazing
the um
that that's coasting i look like snake
thank you very much the uh
yeah
in
in
general so's
sauce
you're supposed to have a certain
percentage of something called housing
sauce which is kind of like chinese
barbecue sauce it's kind of got a very
smoky flavor to it
but hickory barbecue sauce is real close
and that's what they used
that's what the that's what the
vietnamese used in in
they were vietnamese they're not they
weren't chinese they're vietnamese they
were using that in that restaurant
[ __ ] hickory barbecue sauce and it
was [ __ ] mind-blowing it was better
than hosting
well if you can get something cheaper
that's the same flavor profile i mean
you might as well use that but if you
look at the sauce you can look at the
look at the recipe for [ __ ] general
soy sauce
take whatever they tell you for hosting
take that out
and then put [ __ ]
put like a hickory smoked barbecue sauce
in in in its place he will [ __ ] love
it it sucks it real good
it was no joke
grandpa's hammer says after a night of
heavy drinking at mannequins where would
you rather go chantelle's or the massive
chinese buffet
buffet
if i had a choice i'd rather i'd rather
go to a massive breakfast buffet yeah
that's true because i'm super into like
breakfast food yeah i want some eggs or
omelets or pancakes or [ __ ] like that
when i'm drunk but
i don't know man i guess it would depend
on what mood i was in
because honestly like we we go to
chantals a lot of times like when we go
to mannequins because it's right there i
mean it's right there it's like three
doors down
um and their chicken and waffles is
delicious but i can't eat it all it's
massive it's like three big pieces of
fried chicken
on this big huge waffle yeah and i can't
eat it granters asked me question for
tom was general so is a great military
leader or just a great chinese cook he
was a military leader
but i think general cho
general solos might have been slightly
legendary and that dish had nothing to
do with him
that dish did not come from china it
came from taiwan and it's from the 70s
it was uh
a
70s taiwanese
cook
working out of a hotel that came up with
that recipe
and here's the problem
nobody's using that recipe the original
general sauce chicken is unknown
nobody really knows the recipe only he
knew it and some of his friends
and only they remember what it really
tasted like everybody else is using
a recipe that's similar but not quite
there's a whole program on general so's
chicken on netflix you can watch it yeah
it's good that documentary there's only
a couple guys that who knows what the
original one tasted like and he says
he's never tasted it
outside of him and his friends and he
won't give it up this is a [ __ ]
secret kind of like this is like some
martial arts gangster [ __ ]
special [ __ ] kung fu movements and
[ __ ] they're not gonna tell you what the
original
flavor was they're going yeah that's
good but that's not it
but i'm not gonna tell you what you
gotta go to the grand masters because
i'm a [ __ ] to know what general shows
chicken really tasted like
uh but they got is this it and he'll be
like
that's good that ain't it though and
[ __ ] you know
so only they knew what it was and the
dude that [ __ ]
made it is dead only a couple of his
friends are still so no one will ever
figure it out and they won't write it
down and they won't tell anybody
you guys are [ __ ] they ain't got
something they won't tell anybody so
it's like once they're dead nobody will
know how
and nobody don't know what the original
was supposed to taste like yeah
yeah there was a certain thing and it
was it was a
a house meal
from a hotel slash casino i think wasn't
it also a casino i think it was yeah in
taiwan
they named it after a general
mary connolly said yeah in mississippi
my mom from philadelphia
made spaghetti for my granddad he didn't
know what the hell it was
that's funny
yeah it's crazy to think even in our
lifetimes i mean i was a little kid i
was in the 70s
i was born in 1972 in case you guys
didn't know but when i was a little kid
in the 70s
italian food was still seen as kind of
foreign yeah
kind of foreign
um pretty much all you had you know you
had like chef boyardee and cans
and the franco-american stuff in cairns
and you'd have those remember those box
things
was that ship that wasn't chip priority
who who made that was that franco
america it was like it came in a box and
it was like a kit
you know what i'm talking about right
yeah i remember that it was like a kit
that had all it tasted like it was
terrible it was terrible
i mean but but like i said that's
you just grew up with that you didn't
know any better
all the food was kind of terrible like
that
you know grantor's asking me why
colonel parker and colonel sanders why
they were colonels is that some kind of
they never served in the army is that
stolen ballard no it is not
in this in the south
you had carnals
kentucky colonels tennessee cardinals
mississippi colonels
they were
kind of like a local mayor
you could run for a certain office
all right and it's long gone they
haven't been doing this in a long long
time they probably stopped this [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] 50s or 60s
but they were kind of like um
they were kind of like a mayor
you could run for colonel
and you could get that job and you could
live off a [ __ ] stipend they would
pay you to be a colonel
they were crackers
tila's in there laughing her she's going
yeah
her black ass laughing over crack
cracker is not [ __ ]
a cracker is somebody who's cracker jack
he's a [ __ ] who's dressed up
they were in these [ __ ] suits it was
usually like a light-colored suit they'd
sit on the porch and drink [ __ ] tea
and try to sound as intelligent as
possible say they say hater boy no i
don't know boy no don't do it they were
the local
pimp daddy dressing up [ __ ] who
were trying to [ __ ] keep everybody
else in line
they were kind of like in in afghanistan
they would be like your local
leader like your local
taliban leader or something
they were characters they weren't they
didn't have any kind of [ __ ]
authority or any kind of formal
education like you didn't there wasn't a
carnal school or anything like that
a colonel was a dude that you just
elected he ran for it he elected he got
elected by the local population and he
was kind of like a mayor
he would get a check and his job was to
go around and it was kind of ceremonial
if they were going to build a new
building [ __ ] hey you got some
ribbons i want to cut some ribbons on
thai
like that and he'd drink some tea let's
show up
yeah yeah show up for some [ __ ] and
maybe give a speech that's all they did
that's what a colonel did must be nice
so nice work if he can get it
and and really what their skill was was
to dress nice it's ridiculous when you
think about it but that's just the way
the south was
um
but uh no so colonel parker was a
colonel he really was he was a southern
colonel
and uh so was colonel sanders he was a
kentucky colonel
but that's not saying much
it's like a mayor
so in a way it is kind of like stolen
valor because they're not actually like
a colonel colonel like the military
right you weren't military colonels you
were just somebody that dressed nice and
showed up for [ __ ] showed up and [ __ ]
and did ceremonies
they [ __ ] did like ceremonial cutting
a ribbon it was a ceremonial [ __ ] uh
social uh rank it's like hi i showed it
for 15 minutes and i'm getting a check
and now i'm going home and i'm gonna
like have a mint julep on my porch yeah
yeah
kind of like a kind of like the man's
version of being a [ __ ] beauty queen
that's really what it was
yeah essentially he's a man first like
look i just got to show up for some
stuff i got to lean against the car
right look good kind of show something
yeah you all did a good job yeah i did a
great job this is fantastic okay serve
them everybody hey everybody
that's all they did
i'm going to go home and lay on my couch
and
eat some peanut brittle
but in the in the case of colonel parker
connor parker of course was
he was managing elvis or supposedly
managing elvis elvis should have fired
his ass okay
that was would have made a lot more
money and probably lived a lot longer
had he had good management
and then
uh the the colonel sanders actually did
um
start a restaurant chain or so he did
actually get something yeah but it was
more like a direct sales chain
he was selling recipes and spice mixes
to um
um what you call gas stations that
sometimes these gas stations had
attached to them little kitchens
this was before franchising
and over time it kind of evolved into a
corporate franchise where they were
using his recipes and using his image
but he was not a corporate
like aunt jemima and all these all those
[ __ ] people i didn't even think it
was the answer by me even a real person
i think angel woman was a real person i
think i'll go back and some of them
weren't i don't think some of them were
real people they were just surprised you
know uncle benz was a real person but a
lot of times they were based some of
those recipes were big well i know betty
crocker was not a real person that
wasn't a real person i think aunt jemima
might have been actually a real
person uh where was it oh okay jenna
pirate says jello salads were the worst
peas carrots and so on i love all the
[ __ ] this is why i love all this mints i
don't love eating it but i just i love
the history of it i love all the
mid-century stuff because
they called so much [ __ ] salads
that was that is not recognizable as a
salad by today's standards
um you guys can check that out i don't
remember about [ __ ] aunt jemima but
uh some of those black people that were
on those labels were actually real
people
if i remember correctly i don't think
they all were but that was the same with
the white people a lot of those white
people weren't real like i said betty
crocker wasn't a rope yeah
uh
thank you victor what are you all
talking about tonight food is everything
food like always we're always talking
about food
chef boyardee interesting chef that was
a real dude yeah that was a real dude
and uh he was the [ __ ] cordon blue
chef very [ __ ] accomplished yeah did
a lot of [ __ ]
and uh chef boyardee um that wasn't how
you spelled it that was like an
americanized version yeah it was kind of
like the gordon ramsay of his day yeah
he was the real dude
and uh what made him so famous was is
that that was
pre-refrigeration and he was coming up
with recipes for things that could be
canned and eaten at any time which was
the it was old school [ __ ] turn of
the century mre
you could just open it up out of can
start eating it
a lot of times those people didn't even
really heat it
if they did have a [ __ ] central
cooker like central heat which is a
stove back then they'd put the can on it
open the can and put it on the stove and
let it heat in there and then they'd eat
it but you didn't have to heat it a lot
of people didn't
but uh no sh and here's the thing chef
boyardee was basic as [ __ ] that was
basic [ __ ] stuff
when i was a kid
but actually that was
compared to the [ __ ]
italian
sauce recipes that i have from the old
betty crocker cookbook that i have from
the 20s what came out of a chef where a
decant was a lot better a lot more spa
honestly chef buyer new stuff is not bad
not bad at all and honestly eye stuff is
very good yeah yeah i've i've eaten a
couple like like i said out of the
machines it's already out of the
machines it's kind of like you just or
you just eat it at a thing or heat it up
in the microwave it's totally it's
totally incredible
it's a lot better than it was in the 70s
the revenue i like that i like the super
stuffed ravioli yeah real good
that was when i was a kid i used to eat
that spaghetti meatballs the the
beefaroni so a lot of that [ __ ] we made
fun of in the 70s
was actually [ __ ] very futuristic if
you looked at it from the point of view
of the 20s and i kind of feel like shep
rarity is kind of like just like
everything else it had to get better
nowadays tila says chef boyardee was
real damn bless his canned ravioli yeah
yeah he was a real guy real dude um i
think his last name was actually spelled
yeah it was yeah it was boyarty but it
was b-o-i arts again
something like that but yeah it was
spelled like they had to like
anglicanize it yeah it was a new year
boyardee
boyardee yeah that was his last actual
last name but he was actually a chef
yeah that was actually what he looked
like uh i think company man did a thing
about that company too yeah watch
company because i was surprised too i
didn't i thought that was just like
i thought that was that was like some
made up [ __ ]
no that was a real guy he was like jeff
gordon ramsay that was a real guy and he
had cooked for kings across europe and
yeah and stuff that was he was a he had
his own recipe books
and uh no he was and he went through the
[ __ ] french method and used a lot of
[ __ ] italian stuff he was good real
good he was french though i think wasn't
he
or italian well i thought he was italian
uh
he cooked everything he might have been
italian but uh
yeah probably yeah david june says
company man did cover it yeah i thought
he did yeah uh he's he's done like a lot
of i really like that channel but yeah
he's covered i'm pretty sure he's like
right on who these people were yeah
that's what the companies were
fascinating there's a lot more to him
than you think
i was he did one i think it was last
week he did one about
nintendo i think it was about nintendo
yeah and i like people know about it
because of the video games but he's like
man that company's been around since
like the early 20th century
and before they got into video games
they actually did
card games that was the first thing they
started out to like printing playing
cards and then they started trying to
get into all these other industries like
uh rice yeah for whatever reason like
there was a bunch of other [ __ ] that
they did but it's like yeah it's really
interesting
um
yeah david june says tila same you still
love it still get spaghetti and
meatballs from time to time yeah
honestly um
you know i used to work at a print shop
that was right next to a 7-eleven and
sometimes you know i didn't bring
anything from home for lunch or whatever
so i'd toddle over to 7-eleven and see
what they had and every now and then
they had those little you know little
thing of ravioli or a little thing of
spaghetti meatballs a little cup like
that you just heated up 30 seconds in
the microwave
and that was like that was perfectly
good lunch to be honest with you yeah
not bad at all that got better the
franco-american stuff got better too see
i haven't had franco americans because i
kind of feel like
chef boyardee like when i was a kid chef
boyardee was kind of like the better
[ __ ] franco-american was kind of like
rock bottom the ghetto [ __ ]
um
sometimes we'd get frank of like
spaghettios or something because that's
franco-american right and it's like
there's just one the sauce was waterier
yeah like ketchup and it wasn't yeah and
it didn't have and it didn't have the
oomph it wasn't like it didn't have that
nice thick sauce you know like chef i
already had
so franco american it's like you'd eat
it but
hey
i mean when i was a kid it's like well
it was chef boyardee or nothing we
didn't want like that frank
decent now very good
yeah i haven't had i haven't had franco
american since i was little though last
time i had all that stuff but it's been
15 years ago and it was great i was like
oh man this is a lot better than it used
to be
it couldn't stay like it
like it was besides all the stuff that
was exotic back in those days is now
plentiful and cheap so why not put
basil in there
why not put oregano in there i mean it
doesn't cost those exotic spices
well yeah well it was i will show you
people
i have a [ __ ] cookbook from the 1920s
betty crocker cookbook the hat that goes
into the foreign section to tell you how
to make italian food and has to explain
to you what a regular what a race
she's seen it i know explaining to you
well i remember i remember what that was
like because they didn't know what that
was and if you were to actually execute
that tomato sauce you'd hate it there
was nothing in it it'd be like
ketchup with a little bit of oregano in
it there was just no and the thing is is
that they thought that was great well
they didn't that would be better that
was all they had access they didn't know
any better
there was none of this we'll put
parmesan cheese in there we'll put some
basil and some [ __ ] put some wine in
that [ __ ] some garlic garlic and put
some red wine
cook some sausage in it they would they
didn't they didn't think that way they
didn't have those components
only a very rich person would have those
components
and that rich person would be up in l.a
somewhere
in those days or chicago i mean i kind
of feel like particularly i think that
midwestern food particularly
um
very spice averse for a very very long
time like going to a smorgasbord
a swedish smorgasbord they're not not a
single spice in there and i gotta put
that black pepper down that shit's too
hot it's too hot it's too hot
no paprika it's too hot oh
yeah which is great hockey food right
there i mean it's like and and i can't
eat real spicy food anymore either but
i mean black pepper paprika that's like
nothing that's like that's not hot at
all that doesn't read as hot to me
but that's just like very funny that
old-fashioned [ __ ]
glacier glider food was just some
[ __ ]
it's all it didn't taste like anything
no salt a little bit of black pepper
maybe if you were [ __ ] being an
adventurer being adventurous oh let's
let's hold the tabasco my god that
[ __ ] strange ass foreign louisiana
hot sauce we're not gonna put that on
there
i remember when people were like that
they're all dead now
probably although honestly there's still
like some carryover because
even when we remember we were watching
like kitchen nightmares and there were a
few restaurants still left over yeah in
the midwest generally yeah but that was
15 20 years ago they're all dead
so they're dead but yeah even back then
gordon was like what the [ __ ] he's like
these people here yeah they're you guys
don't like
flavor anything like you don't put spice
on anything well think about it that was
2006 2004 and they were in their 70s
then
yeah so they're dead
gone victor says my boss sent back a
chicken fried steak once because the
breading was too spicy
[Laughter]
that's yeah that's that's some really
white [ __ ] right there
really white yeah
i can't imagine it is i was just
thinking about well i was thinking about
midwest food because like i said i was
watching jade the liberty and i was
watching her put that ranch dressing on
that pizza
for her husband and i was just kind of
like oh my god that's the most
midwestern thing i've ever seen what a
white person did back in that day
what a white person did nobody would do
that in florida they would put some
[ __ ]
white creamy stodgy sauce on it that was
kind of [ __ ] cheesy
and salty they'd put that on it
if you had anything that was red
anything that had any kind of [ __ ]
oh
no oh no
[ __ ] it's amazing when you go back
and think about what what the flavor
what the palette and the flavor program
and i'm not like and i'm not saying like
sometimes
sometimes you want that sometimes you
want something that's just kind of like
kind of stodgy or kind of like not all
that
i don't know i don't know every now and
then it's comforting the only thing
stodgy and white sauce that i like is
country gravy on top of maybe country
fried steak
with some [ __ ] hash browns next to it
or maybe some
some mashed potatoes that's nostalgious
i'm gonna get i'm i'm through with that
70s [ __ ] stodgy [ __ ]
i remember [ __ ] denny's denny's was
filled with that stodgy [ __ ] for a while
back in the 80s i mean to be honest with
you i've never been ever since i was a
little little kid
i'm not a big fan of drowning stuff in
gravy or sauce or
i'm not really a big fan of that
honestly if even if i'm gonna eat
cause like other day we you made baked
potatoes like on the grill yeah um i
don't like
tons of [ __ ] on the baked i don't want
like [ __ ] gravy on there i don't want
like tons of sour cream i don't bacon
bits mostly i just want butter and
pepper
and salt
um you know sour cream is good on it too
but i don't want 40 000 things
on it i like to actually taste the
food
rather than so i'm so i'm not a big fan
of like gravy on stuff
honestly even when i'm eating
like for example like pasta with sauce
on it i don't like a ton of salt i like
a little bit of sauce
just enough to like give it a flavor it
says what kind of company makes italian
food and it's called franco-american
yeah franco-american didn't just make
italian food they made a lot of stuff
it's just that i think over time
are they still around i think they are
over time they need spaghettios yeah
yeah spaghetti is a lasagna they made
all kinds of stuff spaghetti inside of
[ __ ] can i'm gonna have to look that
up over time
over time they ended up being in a
competition against chef chef boyardee
stuff yeah so
i mean chef bertie was clearly superior
their sauce was thicker yeah it's
different times but i when i had them
back in back when i was a kid the last i
had them they were identical almost they
were just as good as well franco
american must have their game then
because back when i was a kid franco
american was like that's what you got
when you went to the dollar store
because you were like real short that
month yeah and you had to get
spaghettios and he was like man but you
can make that without the can for
[ __ ] a fraction of the price that's
just [ __ ] i know but
now [ __ ] mike says [ __ ] all y'all for
bashing my bland midwest palette
you get that down
old school swedish palette
one of my seriously one of my favorite
episodes of kitchen nightmares was
that
what was it called fleming's it was a
danish restaurant yeah it was in
miami it wasn't even in the midwest no
miami it was in miami and the couple put
that [ __ ] thank you janet thank you jan
yeah um
it was in miami
and they had bought it from some really
really old [ __ ] yeah and it was like
danish food and everything was like
flavorless yeah for a long time
like and their whole clientele was like
80 year olds yeah
and and it's funny because in miami
yeah and their chef was cuban right and
he's like i don't know what any of this
is he's like i don't know what it is i'm
just telling i'm just making what they
tell me i don't really want to make this
stuff they had it cuban food and all of
a sudden bam places and it was fantastic
yeah
it's miami make you some [ __ ] spicy
ass cuban food yeah duh i'm trying to
find some [ __ ] newer franco-american
they got all kinds of [ __ ] from the
franco-american this guy i didn't even
know they were still around they're
around they were around [ __ ] 20 years
ago 15 years ago
let me see
louis says i've had co-workers swear
they love mexican food and i would get
them real mexican food and they wouldn't
like it they were used to taco bell
yeah taco bell is fine but taco bell is
not mexican food no i guess franco
america no longer exists
see that's what i thought
yeah
i mean taco bell is fine for what it is
um
and taco bell
i'm gonna give them props
they know their target audience their
target audience
is stoners yeah
so they cater to that and they're very
good at it
um
if i'm gonna get tacos
i want you to make them
yeah or i'm gonna get them from
a food truck or somewhere like i'm not
getting from taco bell no franco america
is still around
is it yeah
what are they doing nowadays uh
spaghetti spaghetti no if you're getting
a can what is it what is it lick it
doesn't look that good to me it doesn't
look like it yeah now i'm curious
man they still have the old logo that's
it that's their can that's what they're
showing them i don't understand oh my
god
i don't understand it but my graphic
design bones are just going like
think about it though who would it be i
can't get out of a damn can
i mean you well i would probably
desperate i mean i the the um chef
boyardee spaghetti and meatballs in the
can is actually pretty good yeah
i don't think i've ever had
franco-american
spaghetti from the can and let well when
i was a little kid maybe
we ate spaghettios out of that but it's
not good though
okay for you foreigners
that's what the new chef boyardee
[ __ ]
looks like
it's good actually
but they haven't totally like not bad
that's totally edible and then have
lasagna and beefaroni and different
versions of that i like the ravioli
actually yeah if you're going to get
ravioli ravioli yeah get the super
stuffed ravioli franco american made
spaghettios not [ __ ] um that's what i
said where do you
spaghettio sucked they were so great
they sucked
i mean
like i said the sauce was like water
yeah it was like tomato water it was
back then
even in the 70s we knew that that was
like not that was like the [ __ ]
ghetto [ __ ] yeah was the franco-american
spaghettios
and there's the old school
franco-american [ __ ]
pitcher
franco-american food company
ooh look
look at those [ __ ] kids look at that
look how weird that [ __ ] kid looks
yeah look at that look at that
from another time
he's like yes that's very interesting
extreme close-up i'm trying like every
time he does that like my the lighting
like readjusts itself
and it makes it like really weird
franco-american also has turkey and
gravy look turkey and gravy with the
[ __ ] um in a can in a can with the
[ __ ] [ __ ] now with the [ __ ] uh
what you got
with what stuffy
stuffing turkey and gravy in the can i
don't know how i feel about that that's
like an mre man that's like a [ __ ]
that's like yeah open that [ __ ] up they
also had coffee
frank american coffee in a can in a can
yeah but that's like old though right
yeah old old yeah i was gonna die
frank american macaroni and cheese sauce
oh i remember that you know that yeah
it's like kraft macaroni and cheese box
that's 70s looking [ __ ] yeah
franco-american mushroom gravy
it says sauce all champion
it's mushrooms
you guys it's
all french fries french yeah did you
guys see better off dead please tell me
i'm not hamilton
gravy
oh dear yeah
[Laughter]
gotta get some some major on that [ __ ]
[ __ ] jumping dunking the sandwich in
it
so fancy yeah tila says canned mac and
cheese i know that's got to be nasty
yeah it wasn't a can it was a box it was
a box
does that make it better probably well
just like craft
victor says franco-american is a
conglomerate now they make spaghettios
and semiconductors semiconductors
because those two things go together
well
you know
well spaghettios might be a selling
thing people recognize what a spaghettio
is so they just like people who
who would buy spaghetti i don't know
i mean i kind of feel like carbs you
would buy spaghettios
if you are really broke no you're trying
to survive that's what i'm saying i i
kind of feel like it's going to be like
people that are like look i just need
some [ __ ] food and this is a dollar
they're selling this [ __ ] probably like
roadside [ __ ] convenience that's yeah
that's where it's going which is sad
because it's kind of like man it might
add up though every year
i guess
thank you cheryl can't afford much but
always watch your show happy holidays ah
happy holidays to you too thank you so
much thanks really nice of you
yeah spaghetti is a good survival food i
mean you eat them if you had to
we ate them if we had to when i was
little
even back then in the 70s
you knew that chef boyardee was superior
the thing is though is that
franco-american spaghettios that was
like some [ __ ] that well it was on sale
and they were like 50 cents a can the
thing about eating something like
spaghettios is that it's all carbs
there's not a lot of protein there
it'd be cheaper i mean yeah it is
pre-made you can eat it right out of a
can
yeah you don't have to heat it up
although you should but that's probably
you don't have to
that's it'd be a lot cheaper to just get
some craft macaroni and cheese even
though that's not you have to boil it
but kraft macaroni and cheese be equally
nutritious probably
because there's not much in those hands
the tomato sauce doesn't mean [ __ ]
there's probably more protein than that
[ __ ]
cheese powder
than there is in there probably sauce so
there's not much in either one of those
and you can get crab macaroni and cheese
for like less than a dollar a box
i've seen it for about 75 cents 50 cents
especially the uh store brand i think
it's like 50 cents yeah
and victor says making spaghetti is
easier than making spaghettios
to be honest well to be honest um
you can buy boxes of pasta for very very
cheap
what i used to do when i lived alone and
didn't have a lot of money
i would just buy boxes of pasta
and cook that
and then mix in like a a frozen bag of
vegetables that i got for a buck or
something some bacon bits no i just i
would just put like some spices and [ __ ]
in it yeah
it's good like i don't need bacon bits
and everything i know how you do
bacon bits give me heartburn
you know what i mean
so i don't put bacon bits and everything
the most nutritious thing that ever
comes out of a can
is a can of spam
i know i know you love spam you can live
off of spam
now
above spam
would probably be corned beef hash
you got some potatoes in there and a
bunch of [ __ ] meat
things like corned beef hash people
lived in the 1800s people lived off of
that think of that
they didn't have much
i mean a working class person would
probably be very happy to have a can of
corned beef hash
that was something that my
i i couldn't get into it but
my grandma and my dad ate that a lot
yeah victor said that sounds good it's
like veggie looming yeah that's kind of
i yeah i was into that
i don't need meat and everything i just
like veggies and pasta and stuff like
that
tila says i grew up with my mom putting
cut up hot dogs and spaghetti yeah yeah
my grandma did that yeah my grandma did
that uh we had another thing your mom
used to do back in the day is you take
like
a [ __ ] hot dog and you heat it up the
microwave put some
put it on a [ __ ] tortilla put some
put some like that [ __ ] uh a velvee
the cheese slice and heat that up and
then roll it up and give it to you
you're like a little kid yep and you're
eating the damn
rolled up tortilla with
cheese and a
hot dog in it but you know you're a
little kid
my grandma one thing she would do
she would take hot dogs yeah she would
cut them down the middle
and she would put uh hunks of
american cheese in there yeah wrap bacon
around them
and then put them in the oven and bake
them yeah
and then that's what you would eat for
dinner
with a bacony
cheesy hot dog yeah that was a dinner
yeah they weren't eating that but kids
were eating it
but no
yep
that was what she made kind of for a
while they just they were giving me
things that i wanted which was like kid
food you know
give me a [ __ ] peanut butter jelly
sandwich i ate a peanut brother jenny's
jelly sandwich one time my mom was
amazed that i was silly she used to eat
that and i was like yeah i [ __ ] love
peanut butter peanut butter jelly is
good you used to give those tea when you
were a little boy [ __ ] that's kid
food and i said i [ __ ] love these
things
i know
me and elvis back there [ __ ] eating
fools gold and [ __ ] like [ __ ] you mom
[ __ ] your mom
[Laughter]
my mom's not like that
my mom's awesome yeah but you know
she doesn't judge me yeah
you judge me
my mom's just kind of like
whatever
[Laughter]
i mean you know she had me when she was
very young
yeah
so she was just kind of like whatever
where she was just she's uh just
interested
for me and how we all turned out no need
for me too says hot dogs became pig pigs
in a blanket with biscuits yeah yeah my
grandma made that too that was good too
but one thing that my grandma would do
she did this a lot she would take hot
dogs and she cut them
you know long ways yeah put cheese in
there and then wrap bacon yeah and then
she put them all in a big casserole dish
yeah and she would bake them speaking of
casserole tina was talking about tuna
fish casserole yeah that's another one
that's good oh yeah yeah yeah i see like
bow tie pasta with tuna some kind of a
creamy base with a bunch of peas and
carrots in it and stuff and bake it with
the breadcrumb bread crumb and butter
[ __ ] mix on the top of it so you have
like a crust you can do real well with
that
see the secret
the secret to cooking or the reason why
cooks are cooks and
and this and what makes a good cook a
cook is that you take
ingredients that are not
special they're they're inexpensive and
you try to make something real special
out of it it's easy to take an expensive
uh of
an expensive component
and [ __ ] make something good well
yeah because it's already good because
it's expensive you're just letting that
[ __ ] component speak for itself
you're not supposed to step on that
component you're supposed to go here's
your mind here it is yeah here's your
baha'i mahi so that that component is
speaking for itself
the secret is to take something that
nobody else wants and to turn it into
something like something yeah ham hocks
you wouldn't need a ham hock but if you
[ __ ] cook a ham hock right cut it up
in a bunch of pieces and put it into red
beans and then red beans and rice with
it
that's what you're doing you're taking
something that's not really worth much
you're making something fantastic out of
it like tina's talking about
spaghetti and [ __ ] hot dogs
okay
all you got a spaghetti with spaghetti
sauce you got a pack of hot dogs how are
you going to make that [ __ ] taste good
yeah make that like elevate that [ __ ]
elevate that okay well let's [ __ ]
slice those hot dogs real thin
get a [ __ ] oil really [ __ ] hot and
throw them in there and put a sear on
them so they're nice and crispy and put
them to the side and then you're going
to [ __ ] go ahead and make your
[ __ ] pasta and your sauce and get
that [ __ ] spiced right and you're going
to sprinkle them [ __ ]
[ __ ]
sliced [ __ ] hot dog slices over the
top of that crispy hot dog slices over
the top of that thing over over the top
of that spaghetti and make some [ __ ]
wild ass ghetto ass [ __ ] hot dog
spaghetti you can do it right especially
maybe maybe you might want to bread that
hot dog bread and season those hot dogs
slightly
to [ __ ] give an italian [ __ ]
flavor on you know italian seasoning
maybe a little bit of [ __ ]
um damn seeds not fantasy it's uh
caraway caraway seeds some caraway in
there to make it taste a little bit more
like sausage
you do all kinds of [ __ ] if you have the
components that's this key
it's not taking an expensive [ __ ]
component because they already taste
good right that's what i mean that's
easy or it's easy that's easy right um i
kind of feel like it's
to me it's more um
indicative of a good chef
that can take
cheap ass [ __ ] yeah make it decent and
make it taste like
amazing yeah
that's harder you're elevating
yeah because of something that already
tastes good on its own
and if you all don't believe me look at
the [ __ ] chicken wing
when i was a boy a chicken wing wasn't
worth anything that was [ __ ]
worthless
somebody down in buffalo new york
figured out that if you did a chicken
wing the right way and you tossed it in
[ __ ] a mixture of [ __ ] melted
butter and tabasco sauce a fried chicken
wing you could call it a buffalo chicken
wing and dip it into some [ __ ] blue
and look at where we are nowadays bam
you go to the store that's the whole
thing go to the store and try to buy a
[ __ ] bag of chicken wings they want
to rob you
like you're like you're buying oysters
that's a [ __ ] chicken wing back in
the day a chicken wing wasn't worth
anything
you know nowadays if you want something
[ __ ] that doesn't cost anything
and it's meat it'd be like a turkey neck
just ask my dad
he's full of them he's full of them
if you could get turkey ducks for
nothing then [ __ ] that's what you
wanted to do and if some of those some
of those
piggly wigglies and [ __ ] you can find a
whole pack of [ __ ] turkey necks for
only a couple bucks
and if you know how to cook them you can
turn them into something
well see this is why i'm into like
gordon ramsay [ __ ] yeah because he will
take oxtail
yeah or like nutria yeah nude for you he
did that whole [ __ ] he was in new
orleans new orleans swamp rat
yeah
and he's like i'm gonna make some [ __ ]
out of that i'm gonna make some stew out
of that she calls it nutria it said we
actually just called it nutra
nutra but you know what i'm saying
yeah and it's [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] it's not a rat
it looks like a rat but it's not a rat
it's more like um
beaver or a capibata capivada like that
the small that's kind of what i thought
it was more like a happy butter i
thought like a coffee mug yeah
but well see that's why
gordon ramsay like you know i know a lot
of people think he's a dick but no he's
not dick um
he is well he's not uh snotty
he's like man i will take some local
ingredients yeah and turn that [ __ ] into
something like [ __ ] which to me is
i mean that's kind of like the hallmark
of a great chef
take some like cheap ass ingredients and
make that into something like [ __ ]
sublime
yeah
that's where the artistry of it comes
from
yeah nativa says they put shredded
cheese on tuna casserole crushed up
ladies potato chips on top of it yeah
that worked too
lazy potato chips
or you could take those down
um what do you call them
those fried onion rings those lay's
fried onion rings come in the can put
that on there
oh they sell those around thanksgiving
right yeah they sell them all year round
i mean
they mostly sell them like around
thanksgiving because everybody puts them
on top of the like the green bean
casserole right there's a big big surge
of it yeah but that would be good on on
top i haven't had i haven't had tuna
casserole in a long time i haven't
either that's a 60s dish
it is it's a 60s dish it's good though i
had to figure out how to how to elevate
that
you know you want peas and carrots in it
you know you want a crust on top of it
you know you want a creamy sauce in the
middle of it this is something i had to
figure out
that creamy sauce you might be able to
just do like you did on those green
beans and just use them
some kind of campbell soup creamy mix
like either either the [ __ ] um
maybe like uh some people say well with
the cream of mushroom well what if you
were to use
what if you were to use [ __ ] um
clam chowder
say
clam chowder and tuna
as your [ __ ] base i'm intrigued sound
good
clam chowder that's probably would be
because you have that creamy rich
seafood base
with some clams in it
and you put your [ __ ] tuna in there
to make your base and then you put your
peas and your carrots in there and it
man [ __ ] this [ __ ] we're doing a show i
can't sit here and invent this
invent these meals well that's kind of
what do you think what do you think
clamshell
i think clam chowder would be good cream
new england style clam chowder not
manhattan
and honestly i like both kinds of clam
chowder yeah
just saying right
i'll eat any kind of clam chowder i'm
gonna show you what kind it is i like
both kinds victor says chicken wings are
too expensive consider they grow back on
a chicken like lizards with their tails
[Laughter]
no they don't i'm just gonna grab my
wigs back no they do not
no they do not he's joking it's fine i
just think they're funny how they those
used to be worth nothing and that's
where [ __ ] buffalo chicken wings came
from well that's where just they were
just worth it because somebody figured
out yeah a way to make them delicious
and make them into something well as i
said this is kind of the same thing that
happened with lobster
yeah i mean at least in the northeast
yeah lobster was like garbage meat yeah
we have so much lobster it's everywhere
yeah um
but
for whatever reason victor said google
it no i ain't googling that [ __ ] man
arms do not grow back bro
tina said clam chowder will work too tom
so yeah i think it would be even better
honestly one of these days
we've been like thinking a long time
it's like we need to make like some
homemade clam chowder yeah or some
seafood i can make it
i used to make seafood chowder
because if you don't have clams you can
use just some white fish
i'll eat that the same thing i'll eat
that all these fish yeah it's good
seafood
seafood is like my favorite thing i will
eat pretty much anything out of the
ocean oh well but you know within reason
within reason but
all that stuff out of the oh it's so
good hugo laughing at me for some reason
i don't know what he taught me
see the santa seafood boil sounds good
too yeah we haven't had one of those in
a while
yeah it's been like it's been a while
crowd has been expensive maybe
we did one we did one
what like a year ago more than that year
and a half something like that just
before the pandemic
okay so it was two years ago we went
down to win dixie and [ __ ] scored on
a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] crab legs yeah
crab legs and then
then the woman working there the girl
working there i guess she was kind of
gothic or something she gave us a bunch
of extra she's just look i got a bunch
of other ones she's like just throw
these out here just take this okay i was
like okay and they're like yeah yeah
yeah man free [ __ ]
[ __ ] big old [ __ ] bags of [ __ ]
uh and then we sat there and ate all
them damn clean crab those crab legs man
[ __ ] they were nice
real good haven't had it in a while we
had like in the bedroom we had like the
coffee table we had newspaper and paper
bags yeah we're sitting there right over
the [ __ ]
half cup potatoes yeah corn crab legs
shrimps yeah
yeah it was good corn cobs
man that was good
we had big old bowls of melted butter
yeah
man that was that was delicious
yeah
like i said
seafood [ __ ] man i will eat that [ __ ]
all day long all day long so we've been
talking for about food forever
everybody's dropping off i think about
30 something people in there now and
then they're talking everybody's talking
about food yeah
well that's where you can have food
shows like sure
victor says i'm not sure if i like
seafood or if i just like tartar sauce
yeah i mean tartar sauce is good
cocktail sauce is good yeah easy to make
and
like i said
ever since i was a kid i'm just
man i'm a seafood person yeah i love
that [ __ ] i love that [ __ ] i will eat
fish if you
give me a choice of all the meats
always going to be fish
or something that comes out of the ocean
that's the first thing i'm going to pick
it's just expensive that's
the only reason why we're not eating at
all time i know
if i could i would i would eat shrimp
all the time i would [ __ ] fish all
the time we got this southern [ __ ]
[ __ ] we got this uh chain of southern
fried
seafood it's a place called captain d's
and uh
it's good you get fried green tomatoes
and everything and only black women work
in there they're cooking that [ __ ] so
[ __ ] they're taking this just
seriously
that's [ __ ] good restaurant
and it's just like it's like the old
south
um [ __ ] you can go down in there for
about 20 bucks
maybe 25 bucks a person
you can get
fried fish like fish and chips
shrimp
stuffed crabs
fry clams they got fragrant tomatoes
also fried green tomatoes
biscuits and [ __ ]
sweet tea
what else did they have corn
yeah um
man that place is so good
and
like the tartar sauce and the cocktail
sauce you just get it out of the damn
machine squirting it yeah
yeah
and you go in there and [ __ ] this
it's just people in the sunday best old
black dudes in their [ __ ] sunday
suits and [ __ ] [ __ ] and just like
they're getting ready to play blues
music or something it's [ __ ] funny
you know in a certain way it is kind of
a
when you look at it
it look to the average person would look
like a fast food restaurant but it isn't
they're run kind of like a mom paw type
restaurant each one of them is a little
bit different
it's not nothing like [ __ ]
long john silver's it's nothing like
that it's just
it's kind of like i don't know if you
guys have ever been to a [ __ ] howards
remember howards
i don't but yeah it was that was some
mississippi [ __ ] there yeah there's a
[ __ ] that's where you go get like a
hamburger with chili on it and stuff
it's like that kinda
they're good
they're good though
mmm
seafood but they have they don't they
have crab don't they
stuffed crab that's all i see i don't
think they have crab legs do they
no no just stop i think so stop grabbing
blue crabs i think you can get gumbo
there
yep yeah
they got all the southern [ __ ] all this
other stuff and all this all the you
know southern [ __ ] like [ __ ]
louisiana oh you can get all that [ __ ]
although i kind of feel like there's not
it's not real widespread that chain it's
a chain yeah but it's not roll by itself
it's not everywhere captain d's
it's worth it it's good it's kind of
have a kind of a real comfortable casual
dining experience
it's not cheap
but you're getting more for your money
um
if you go to a place like red lobster
you're going to get more of a [ __ ]
corporate kind of a little bit more of
an elevated type dining experience but
to me it's corporate
captain d's feels very southern it feels
very 70s or 80s
instead of charging you for [ __ ]
decor and [ __ ] fancy booths and [ __ ]
you're just paying for the food
and it's been always been cooked real
well
those people [ __ ] care about that
food when they cook it
and it does it it's very southern
tila says i love a good fish and chips
too yeah they have yeah
they they honestly when i was in the uk
my favorite thing
fish and chips and everybody every
single corner
had a decent fish and chips place yeah
that also had indian food usually
with if you talk about british fish and
chips you want tartar sauce you want
fries of course but you also want that
damn malt vinegar yeah they didn't have
tartar sauce
malt vinegar just the vinegar
which i'm not a huge fan of
gotta you british people don't
understand the beauty of tartar
absolutely vinegar together is [ __ ]
really good it's good on it's i like
tartar sauce just on the damn french
fries
it's just good yeah that is good it
works real well
a lot of extra calories though because
you you end up eating a lot of damn
tartar sauce
tartar sauce i like on
certain things on certain kind of fish
if you people don't know what it is
it's a white sauce based in mayonnaise
we might have probably half sour cream
and half mayonnaise
with uh dill and dill pickle
cubes in it
usually some um onion
it's just [ __ ] good man i mean just
white any kind of fish or or potatoes
dunked in that is just great
and like i said
high inc high in calories high in fat
and i mean
americans die early because of all these
[ __ ] delicious sauces that we got
from [ __ ] french people and [ __ ]
british people and [ __ ] over the years
oh the french people don't die of that
[ __ ]
goddamn wine
maybe that's what it is
maybe we should drink more wine right
and um
black people didn't help with all that
deep frying and make coming up with all
this [ __ ] new [ __ ] and everything it
makes everything taste good so good
people [ __ ] spin that [ __ ] around
south you go
they're like look we're taking some [ __ ]
that wasn't even that good yeah we're
gonna make it ta-da it's delicious and
you're just like god damn it
god damn it yeah
yeah now it's good why did you do that
they trying to get revenge on us
maybe that's what it is
come up with some [ __ ] [ __ ] we're
gonna go yeah okay
gotta say that well okay so we're
talking about like
i mean fish and chips in the uk
it's weird because like i lived over
there for a while and it's just like i
ate fish and chips like all the time
but i didn't get fat
i'm not really sure like i lost weight
while i was over there
i don't know if it was because
i was walking everywhere or
i don't know what it was yeah
um
i don't know people don't get fat over
there the way
well it might be different nowadays but
when i was living there in the mid to
late 90s it's the walking probably i
mean
when i was in boston i'd walk [ __ ]
seven to eight miles a day just going
through the trip well i didn't have a
car so i was just kind of like oh i'm
gonna go to the train and it's like and
i'm like walking around the town or
whatever and it's just like i wasn't
even thinking about it right outside of
a city in the united states you're gonna
drive everywhere
there's you just can't walk anywhere it
thinks far away everything's far away
yeah i kind of feel like that's yeah
yeah that's one kind of [ __ ] well
there's nothing two miles from you
everything is [ __ ] six miles from you
yeah you have to drive you have to drive
yeah the club well florida right
is one of the worst places for that
you can't walk
this neighborhood does not even have
sidewalks no
our old neighborhood did there's nowhere
to walk to
you're in the country and yeah yeah the
only place i can walk to is dollar
general yeah
but there's nothing over there really
i can walk to a dollar generally get
some iced tea that's about it there's
nothing else to walk to right yeah
nothing there are horse farms and that's
it
so
i think it's funny because you have your
european people why don't you have
that's funny i'd run into the european
people's you need to have public
transportation
public transportation what are you
talking about well the distances are
much better
[ __ ] too [ __ ] fast which i wish we
did honestly because if we had that i
would do it because i don't like to
drive
but
the distance is too the distances are
much farther right and it's so it's like
a much bigger outer tail it's a huge
country
i mean where we live
it's not in the middle of nowhere
everything is spread out but it's very
very spread out everything is spread out
where we live the closest thing i can
walk to a dollar general it's about a
mile from here maybe or half a mile oh
no half a mile it's a half mile right
um circle k is about a mile now circle k
is about a mile and a half from here
i could walk to that if i had to yeah
but the thing is there's no sidewalk
you'd be walking there's no size yeah
there's no sidewalk yeah
no sidewalk you walk across the grass
whole time so yeah it's just it's all
the roads yeah or across people's yards
yeah take it out
people don't walk anywhere
they might ride a bicycle
well back in the day
before i had a car
i grew up in daytona and i used to walk
everywhere and people used to look at me
like i was a [ __ ] freakazoid
or walking places
well i had to walk places i don't have a
car yeah
so i had to walk
but
nobody watched most people don't have
cars they want to travel if they don't
have a car or whatever they just ride a
bicycle
you'll see bicycles
bicycles and motorcycles
a lot of motor scooters you can get a
motorcycle
you get a motor scooter for under a
thousand dollars you can get a 500 motor
scooter
and ride it on the road
or not ride it on the road the cops
don't really care
whether or not that motorcycle that that
uh that thing is legal or not
so uh cheryl says i don't drive i walk
everywhere honestly i kind of wish on
where you live i wish i didn't have to
drive
yeah but where we live now you have to
drive because there is nothing within
walking distance right
i wish i could walk everywhere
with bullet trains in the united states
you're in san francisco though the the
situation in the rest of the country
just doesn't suit a bullet train a
bullet train is [ __ ] high-speed rail
from one [ __ ] city to a next where
there's a lot of transit and a lot of
commuting
the age of commuting is kind of gone
people don't drive to work
like they used to especially since the
pandemic
um
and nobody
just because you get downtown that
doesn't mean that you're close to where
you work [ __ ] everything is [ __ ]
spread out it's just
well like i said florida's especially
doesn't really work everything is spread
out
um if you live in florida yeah
you have to have a car you have to have
a car i
grew up in florida and i didn't have a
car for a long time and it was a giant
pain in the ass yeah public
transportation is there but it's very
very minimal yeah we have trains and
buses and all kinds of stuff and i
wouldn't even scratch the surface it
doesn't get i mean honestly you need to
go what i did
when i i grew up in daytona
what i had to do
i had a job
i didn't have a car
i had to take a bus
to one point
and then i had to get off the bus
and then walk
a mile to my job
because the bus didn't stop there
yeah and if you set up a system where
buses and trains stopped everywhere it
would immediately start running into the
red
because you wouldn't have enough people
on the damn things to [ __ ] make it
economically viable because there's just
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] out in the middle
of the door everywhere and you're not
going to concentrate them you can't
concentrate americans
they just they do not like to live i
mean this is a well it's a massive place
it's a massive place and most people do
are not born and raised in high
density population zones they're raised
in very low density populations and
that's how they like it
you move them into a more urban or even
suburban environment you're like oh man
too many people and they'll move back
out of the country
the [ __ ] people don't realize how
many [ __ ] americans live in the
country
and they're gonna drive or ride bicycles
or ride motorcycles
and they don't care about your city they
just don't
well americans are used to driving a lot
farther yeah for whatever reasons yeah i
don't like to drive so it's it's not
really my thing but take them cars away
they'll just buy horses and [ __ ]
horses are actually probably more
damaging to the environment they eat
everything they [ __ ] everywhere they
[ __ ] uh
when when
england and when london was horse
powered they had a very hard time
getting rid of all the damn horse [ __ ]
it's there's no easy solutions to
anything and there are no solutions
things just go the way they are people
don't need to worry about it
civilizations don't last long anyway
for all we know we'll be back we'll be
back in a medieval era within a hundred
years anyway
probably not but okay it's possible it
wouldn't be the technology wouldn't be
on wouldn't i don't think technology
will ever go backwards yeah so that's
not going to be the same so it wouldn't
quite be the same as many people it's
just that it wouldn't be
it won't be centralized it'll be very uh
and it wouldn't surprise me uh most most
people are
most intelligent kind of
estimations say that the populations
will start declining soon that
everything is starting to decline you
just don't really it's not the
industrial revolution you don't need
large populations anymore
um
because
it's not a population-based economy
anymore
we'll just have to see how it goes i
don't care it's uh beyond my expiration
date i'd be dead by then
digit maniac says i've never owned a car
i'm in the suburbs of new york long
island yeah everyone here has a car but
i can get around on a bike yeah or take
a train or uber anywhere else i need to
i don't use the buses though yeah when i
was living in honestly like i would kind
of like that situation because i don't
like to drive i can drive uh but i don't
really like to when i was in boston for
many for several years there was no
absolutely no need for a car until i
became a salesman and it was and i
wasn't living in boston or wasn't
selling in boston we're at wellesley
western dover era area which is kind of
higher end suburbs
now if you live in [ __ ] a city like
that you just don't need a car it'd be a
pain in the ass why would you send why
would you spend money on something like
that honestly i would like to be
somewhere where i didn't need to drive
anywhere i would really like to be able
to walk to most [ __ ] i needed yeah or
take a or a bicycle to it well you kind
of like that now in some ways
we're not a big difference
i can't walk anywhere there's no reason
to go anywhere i can walk to dollar
general that's about it
well and then [ __ ] you got the
grocery store a mile and a half away but
you can just get in the car and [ __ ]
be there in two minutes and then come
right back and really you know it's only
like once a week to buy groceries
so
it's close to that
you're actually on transportation
spending less now than you would would
be spending on it in boston because you
have to pay to park it
and uh your tags cost a lot less
and then i think it mostly sits but you
do need it
you know
yeah groceries yeah and it goes
somewhere
so it ends up working out
but in boston
especially towards this you know the
city boston somerville
having a car was
you didn't really need it
unless you had to leave the city well i
kind of feel like in a big city you
probably don't need you really need to
be
because you can walk or take a
subways or subway or whatever like i
said if i lived in new york city i would
absolutely not have a car no you
wouldn't be able to park it anywhere and
why bother it'd be like flushing money
down the toilet yeah you can walk to
whatever you wanted to walk to or take a
subway people that live in those areas
have no concept of what life is outside
and if you wanted to
drive to another city like to visit
family you could just rent a car right
so yeah why would you pay to have one
but in my experience people that come
from those cities because i live there
have no concept of what it's like to
live outside of those cities if they've
never lived outside there and a lot of
them have it so they try to they try to
project their needs and their situations
on people outside
nah there's no public transportation and
the world is a lot bigger than those
areas
um you know [ __ ]
30 miles in boston is a long way 30
miles here is nothing
you can get there quickly
you know
i can get 30 miles away within
20
minutes
to get 30 miles away in downtown boston
that might take 45 minutes
well i mean an hour
bang on traffic
we go downtown club in yeah
downtown stanford or downtown orlando
downtown sanford
about
12 15 miles
downtown orlando about 20 25 miles yeah
not a big deal no downtown stanford we
can get there within a half hour
yeah
but like i said i'm not a big fan of
driving i always make him drive yeah i
drive she doesn't drive so
i mean i'll drive if i have to i drove
to
you know ocala to see my mom a couple
weekends ago
so i will drive but i would like prefer
not to
i'd prefer not to
i wish everything was like
right there
but you know
that's that's not how [ __ ] goes
especially not in florida
um
where am i
where did pookie go oh she's running
around did she leave she got bored of us
yeah baby she got bored of us
uh strong 78 that's one thing that i got
taken aback by moving from cali to
florida car insurance
yeah i don't know well is it more
expensive yeah if you don't need it
honestly i barely drive my car
but obviously i still have to pay
insurance on it i have it at the minimal
but it's still
85 a month
which you know
that's expensive
but you have to have it
in
case honestly a long time ago we did
talk about
getting rid of the car
and just about [ __ ] renting one and
just whenever we needed one just running
it which might have been cheaper in the
long run
the price and i'm not sure that that's
not still the case it might be but the
problem is is that whenever i wanted to
rent one the [ __ ] didn't have
one in stock to rent
that's true that's what turned me off to
that better to just have that [ __ ]
sitting there because wherever i need to
go anywhere i can just jump in it and
leave i don't have to arrange it with
some other company
i have motorcycles and stuff but you
know
what time is it jenny
8 851 okay it's almost nine boy you
drank this [ __ ] out of that [ __ ] yeah
well i don't know about you but i'm
getting ready to [ __ ] shut this down
get us leaving
you want something to eat
yeah all right we want to eat
i don't know what do we got make
something
what do we got got all kinds of stuff
what was it like tempt me come on
um
i got spaghetti sauce made
okay that's and i have ziti already made
oh okay
and uh i'm a tree i can put some kind of
protein in there
i'm gonna drink maybe or veggies or i
could do that yeah like mushrooms do we
have any more mushrooms oh okay
but i think i'd probably want some kind
of protein maybe uh i got some
i got uh some hamburger patties i could
probably cook and then dice up and put
that in there
because that's faster than see i have
that those big old rolls of
hamburger but that takes a long time to
thaw yeah let's not worry about that
yeah i mean let's have some
angus beef hamburger patties i could
cook and then break apart and put into
the sauce well do what you got to do but
honestly ramen
okay now that's i have ramen
again i have a bunch of eggs
okay
yeah you want ramen or would you rather
have spaghetti would you have ramen
all right so
you can put mushrooms in the ramen right
yep and hard-boiled eggs yep
i kind of feel like that sounds better
you want to do that
okay we can do that
because we have mushrooms we got
mushrooms got to use up i got oriental
frozen vegetables
oh now with [ __ ] you're gonna put that
in there too you put that in there it's
got [ __ ] all the it's got it's got
um they call them broccoli
yeah
red and yellow peppers
and it's got [ __ ] water chestnuts
yeah see veggies mushrooms yeah yeah
with that and eggs come into it i'm down
i'm down okay i don't need meat just do
you want any kind of cream base in it or
you just want to [ __ ] don't notice
you want don't base or you want chicken
um shrimp okay cause i got the shrimp
okay we do that i think i have a korean
one left for myself
if not that's hot there right yeah
that's for me though well yeah if not
i'll just take a [ __ ] another shrimp
and like you have
yeah okay
i mean that sounds good actually okay we
can do it
all right look at her tina look she's
drunk
well yeah running a drink
uh
we're gonna go in the other room and
watch watch movies you wanted a drink he
wants to split mine
pour some ears in mine my tequila though
oh yeah that's right okay i'll make you
another drink go ahead and shut it down
people i forgot
he's got tequila yeah i don't like that
[ __ ] i get it all right
so we're gonna we did a good we did a
good thing
yeah we did a good thing well almost
four hours yeah
this one was three and a half hours and
like the first one that
stopped working for whatever reason was
half an hour so i don't know what that
was all about
it happens
i get frustrated
he tells me like
i like i turned it off i'm like [ __ ]
i've been like well because i've been
dealing with this other computer and i
was just kind of like i was trying to
figure out because this other computer
that i have is just kind of like it's a
pc and that's my editing computer
and i don't know what the [ __ ] is the
matter with it but
it's really really slow
and i downloaded this program
and it told me hey this program that you
have is like malware
so i got rid of that and i think i fixed
it
but
i don't know we'll see we'll see how it
goes
so i get very very frustrated which it
doesn't like work to my specifications
i'm just saying
go watch gremlins jenny
um you know
honestly today i watched i've been doing
like all winter horror movies well
mostly i've been doing all winter horror
movies this month because i'm
reviewing them so today i watched
frozen from 2010
it's the one with the three people
trapped on the ski lift
did you guys see that one okay so that
was really good i watched that while i
was wrapping christmas presents
so i'll put up a review of that but
it'll probably be after christmas though
because i have a whole bunch of ones
that are like in the pipeline
mango says it's been a great show thank
you very much
uh you know
all right so
here we go we're gonna like
stop it for tonight we're gonna have
some ramen maybe whatever the [ __ ] he's
making i don't know what he's doing down
there
i'm have a warmer drink
hopefully you guys have a good weekend
coming up everybody
keep it safe out there
keep doing what you're doing
we will see you guys on sunday we're
either going to talk about
identity which rob sent us
or we're going to talk about nightmare
alley which i'm planning on going on
seeing going and seeing tomorrow
one of those two things
so we'll be back sunday everybody have a
good weekend up until then and we will
see you guys
then thank you for super chats thank you
for hanging out with us on this friday
night and we will see you on sunday
afternoon bye